bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouvel
épisode des deux probablement
aujourd'hui j'accueille samuel bizeray
monsieur cm point d'interrogation
j'ai pas dit ça va la forme où ça ira
mieux quand j'aurai fini mon café mais
ça va pour la transforma ça va bien
c'est très bien la forme est ce que tu
vas commencer par un peux te présenter
comment est-ce que tu en est venu à
fierté chaîne youtube et tout ce que tu
fais bah écoute moi je suis je suis un
petit peu je me je me sens un petit peu
comme un imposteur dans tout le décorum
j'ai envie de dire moi je suis surtout
un un ancien croyant en fait je suis
surtout quelqu'un qui est qui a plongé
tête la première dans dans énormément de
croyance désolé ça c'est parce que je
suis dans un open space ça va arriver le
tuteur moi c'est parce que donc voila
moi je si tu veux j'étais très j'ai
beaucoup d'affinités avec les idées
newedge euse les g jouer les ufologues
pendant un moment j'ai été élevé dans
les témoins de jéhovah j'ai cru en dieu
pendant très longtemps j'ai lu la bible
de la première à la dernière page j'ai
eu une partie du coran etc
donc je me suis je tirais les cartes du
tarot qu'est ce que je faisais encore
d'autres j'ai fait de la radiesthésie
figure toi aussi je sais alors la
radiesthésie à la base c'est censé être
les mecs qui sait qu'il trouve de l'eau
avec des baguettes mais en fait plus
globalement ça implique le fait de
percevoir si je me trompe pas je me
ferai peut-être tirer les oreilles par
mes collègues c'est implique le fait de
percevoir la présence à distance
d'objets ou de choses d'où de matières
en fait donc voila moi je moi je
plongeais à fond dans tous ces trucs là
et puis par chance j'insiste vraiment
là-dessus par chance j'ai été amené à
mort à me remettre en question et j'ai
j'ai compris le sens de la méthode
sceptiques qui m'a totalement
bouleversée qui m'a totalement remis le
cerveau en place et maintenant mais je
pense que j'ai un petit plus à apporter
à cette communauté qui est le fait que
je comprends comment on est quand on
pense une croyance quand on est dans la
croyance
j'essaye donc de montrer que les gens
qui croient des trucs même complètement
absurdes sont pas spécialement bête pour
autant ou en tout cas moi je me sens pas
plus intelligent parce que j'ai appris
la méthode sceptiques et sont pas non
plus spécialement malveillants come on
come on pourrait trop vite le croire
c'est intéressant donc technique c'était
par chance à ce que tu expliquer un peu
plus mais si tu veux moi je vais te
faire l'historique rapidos c'est juste
que c'est pas une histoire super joyeuse
donc tu veux pas non plus plomber
l'ambiance dans les cinq premières
minutes je donc moi j'ai une grande
carrière dans le sillage d'une grotte
carrière j'ai une longue carrière dans
le cinéma
j'en ai vécu pendant plus de 20 ans
pendant presque 20 ans et donc il se
trouve qu'à un moment donné j'étais en
train de réaliser mon film qui s'appelle
saturday man qui est un truc
complètement délirant cas rien à voir
avec les eti 6 et bon ben voila quand tu
réalises un film c'est une pression
immense sais je ne venais pas
connaissance en tout cas de métier plus
+ arras en plus plus horrible que celui
d'un réalisateur et et quand tu es dans
la croyance et que tu es sous pression
mais fatalement tu utilises tout est
petit outil était donc moi j'étais dans
une telle pression il y avait le
directeur de prod qui avait fait un
détournement d'argent ça c'était l'enfer
que je que je dirais les cartes tous les
jours tu vois j'étais tous les jours
j'étais avec mes tarot avec mais machin
j avais le tarot en ligne tu vois je te
la clique les flics je veux des réponses
et ce que je fais des bons choix est ce
que je fais des bons choix
et pendant ce tournage sur lequel mon
cousin qui j'étais très attaché comme un
frère vraiment comme un frère mais des
il était aussi acteur de mon film il se
trouve qu'ils décèdent
voilà il décède dans un accident de la
route et son décès est entouré de deux
cygnes en fait il ya plein de
coïncidences qui font que ce décès a
l'air destiné en gros mais ces signes
sont contradictoires entre eux et je
comprends rien je comprends pas ce
qu'ils veulent me dire ces signes et là
je je suis vraiment dans un état de
nausées absolue de
de tout ce système de croyance et je dis
bon voilà c'est terminé que ces trucs
existent ou pas je veux plus rien avoir
à faire avec ça ça me rend fou et je me
mets dans un état neutre si tu veux
et dans cet état neutre j'ai un ami qui
quelques mois après qui est venu boire
j'ai tiens regarde la chaîne youtube
heures qui s'appelle gus dx qui fait de
la chasse aux fantômes ne sais pas si tu
connais le travail de biche dx donc
c'est assez taille ou tubes heures qui
s'accrochent des caméras très
sympathique qui a l'air de très bonne
foi et il va dans des lieux réputé hanté
et il appelle les fantômes tu vois il se
met dans noir il appelle les fantômes
mais il est comme tout le monde ici il
se fout une trouille phénoménale et je
reste un bon client de ses productions
d'ailleurs et c'est assez drôle parce
que je me dis voilà si quelqu'un peut
avoir la preuve de l'existence de l'au
delà c'est lui parce que je croyais en
sa bonne foi donc quelque part en me
disant je vais avoir des nouvelles de
mon cousin
tu vois quelqu'un qui est décédé et un
jour gus dx film une boîte à outils donc
si tu veux il ya un plan comme ça fixe
sur une table il ya une boîte à outils
elle est bien posée et janry une
demi-heure après lui il est en train de
crapahuter dans le truck une demi-heure
après la boîte à outils elle tourne et
elle tombe télékinésie prix sur caméra
je me dis ça y est il a eu la preuve
ça y est c'est bon c'est gagné et je me
dis bon et va pas s'emballer on sait
déjà votre et quelquefois avec des
conneries comme ça on va vérifier que je
télécharge la vidéo je rassemble toutes
les séquences de ce plan de caméra et je
vois qu'il ya une variation de la
luminosité pile à l'endroit de la la
boîte à outils et cette variation de la
luminosité et la en forme de carré bon
ça sent le gros patch tu vois découpage
after effects collée dessus donc et je
me dis bon je suis toujours dans cette
dans cette démarche de prudence jeudi on
va pas l'accusé je vais juste dire voilà
gus j'ai trouvé ça il faut aussi que tu
expliques ça j'en fais une vidéo
je me rappelle les limites j'ai
longtemps hésité à faire cette vidéo
parce que je trouvais ça assez appel au
clash et c est la vidéo sort elle fait
un mini buzz
instantané à l'époque j'aurais dis un
gros buzz voilà et ça ça a été vraiment
le pivot la tronche en biais que je
considérais comme des ennemis à l'époque
c'était les esthéticiens ces gens qui
refusent tout par par croyance la
tronche-en-biais me félicite pour cette
démarche mais et 7 félicitations là ça a
été le moment d'inversion si tu veux
donc j'insiste vraiment sur le
l'importance de féliciter les gens qui
font ça aussi pour les sceptiques
font un effort même s'ils ne font pas
l'effort complet dans lequel on s'attend
à ce qu'ils viennent s'ils font un petit
pas dans notre direction
félicitons les déjà quoi tu vois même
s'ils n'arrivent pas aux conclusions
qu'on voudrait qu'ils arrivent et voilà
un petit peu comment je me suis lancé
dans cette aventure les gens vont
apprécier cette démarche ensuite et puis
comme j'avais déjà fait pas mal de blogs
pour mon film il y avait un petit bagout
qui passait pas trop mal les vidéos sont
succédé après il ya eu la révélation des
pyramides et c'est ok c'est c'est très
inspirant
c'est pas tout à fait réplicable jeu
magique ray d'autres personnes mais
malheureusement non mais il ya des
petits éléments intéressants tu vois la
félicitation l'état neutre aussi vrai
dans lequel elle entretient épistémique
permet de se plonger
on en reparlera peut-être plus tard
enfin voilà y aller il ya des trucs là
dedans qui m'inspire pas mal qui sont
rarement exposés voilà donc sa séquence
s'est il ya cinq ans et cinq ans du coup
juste après ça tu te dis je me lançais
un petit peu plus à réfléchir à un truc
sceptiques enfin comment ça s'est passé
après évidemment je tombe sur celui que
je considère comme le saint patron
christophe michel hygiène mentale
mon premier commentaire sur sa chaîne
est un commentaire de rageux puisqu'ils
s'étaient la vidéo je retrouve ce
commentaire et que je me lance quatre
d'ailleurs pour mon histoire personnelle
il est sa vidéo sur le
les ovni comme quoi ce serait un
phénomène social et ce qui est pas du
tout faux à l'époque je largue est que
si c'était un phénomène social alors il
faudrait aussi expliquer pourquoi il y
avait une telle variation des formes
vatra vers le temps qu'ils n'étaient pas
corrélés avec l'image concentré au
cinéma enfin bon voilà après le sujet
ovni est un sujet qui me semble
personnellement un peu plus complexe que
le que peut connaître le sujet des
fantômes ou etc
pour plein de raisons mais on reste
quand même en deçà du niveau de preuve
satisfaisant que pour pouvoir émettre
des hypothèses avec la moindre certitude
enfin tout cas voilà ça c'est ma nation
maintenant à l'époque j'étais tout
frustré je croyais encore si tu veux
qu'il y avait des des croyances en fait
qu'ils étaient encore bien ancré en moi
je pensais qu'elle avait encore droit de
cité comme le 11 septembre mais les
ovnis je ne sais pas tout n'est pas faux
c'est pas possible
et c'est là qu'on est du coup je me
fasse à ses amis combien de temps avant
que tu te sois vraiment convaincu par la
méthode sceptiques
c'est une bonne question je sais que je
crois que c'est bronner qui disait
gérald bronner donc le sociologue qui
disait que ça mais à peu près autant de
temps à ceux des convertir que le temps
qu'on a passé dans une conversion pour
le coup pour le coup c'est pas vrai
parce que moi j'ai vraiment passé toute
ma vie à croire j'ai toujours été le
mulder à l'école tu vois donc les
méthodes sceptiques elles m'ont vraiment
cas voilà je sais ce qui m'a ce qui a
vraiment été un tournant
et ça aussi c'est un élément super
important dont on ne parle pas assez
ce qui a été un tournant c'est le moment
où je me suis rendu compte que grâce à
cet ensemble de méthodes je commence à
être capable de comprendre le discours
des scientifiques mais c'est à dire que
les conférences dit de vulgarisation qui
sont très très loin d'être accessible à
tout le monde malheureusement ça c'est
un truc qu'on oublie un peu un peu trop
souvent il est tout d'un coup les
conférences de vulgarisation jeu je
comprenais que il n'y avait aucune
raison pour lesquelles je pourrai pas
les comprendre et ça m'a permis de
découvrir la physique quantique la
relativité etc
j'ai plongé là dedans je viens gaver
comme c'est pas permis et ça ça a
vraiment été le moment où je me suis
engagée si tu veux mais je me suis je me
suis dit la science la science peut
aussi m'appartenir encore en gros n'est
pas en tant que scientifique ou quoi
mais je peux je peux comprendre ce que
ce qu'elle est je peux comprendre ce
qu'elle a à donner
et puis et puis très vite on y retrouve
aussi parce que le croyant ce qui se
vend le croyant entre guillemets un
nouveau on va utiliser des mots assez
profane est difficile à définir mais le
croyant ce qu'ils cherchent c'est c'est
un peu de merveilleux c'est un peu d'eau
de la baie et ce à la science la porte
en fait mais il faut faire une démarche
vers elle il faut faire un pas vers elle
pour le pour le comprendre et le saisir
mais voilà qui dirait que la libération
n'était pas accessible
oui je sais c'est un grand truc qui ne
me semble pas très conscientisé de la
part des à la fois des youtube dont je
m'inclus dedans 1 et 2 et d'aider des
scientifiques
c'est que en fait on passe complètement
à côté de ça parce que on se situe veut
il n'y a pas en fait je vais faire très
simple le premier qui a réussi à
vraiment me faire m'intéresser à la
science à part les documentaires
évidemment mais les documentaires on
sait qu'ils sont souvent souvent assez
criticables l'image de l'atome qui
persiste un petit peu dans l'esprit
collectif ce genre de truc c'est bruce
de la chaîne i bandai brousse
il a un truc qui rend la vulgarisation
non seulement accessible mais en plus
j'ai envie dire plus que fun j'ai envie
de dire swag qui est bruce des sciences
et swag exactement il a il a apporté un
truc alors c'est imperceptible et c'est
pas c'est c'est une espèce d'humour en
fait je sais pas comment le camp
expliqué il fait partie de deux des
youtube heures si tu veux un peu un peu
fun et c'est qu'on peut retrouver dans
le top 5 de webedia et il avait la
science avec lui alors que nous j'ai
l'impression qu'on est plus dans une
démarche de de délivrer de la science et
ensuite on essaye quand même de la
rendre attrayante de la rente ferme de
la rendent accessibles c'est alors cette
la priorité de ces deux là
c'est de l'impression tout ça je ne suis
pas très fort belle là-dessus mais je
pense que ce en brousse je n'aurais pas
eu le marchepied aurait permis ensuite
d'atteindre des conférences comme les
extraordinaires conférence me retrouve
sur les mardis de l'espace de six ans
rennes ou ou des trucs comme ça où nos
contenus quoi tu vois je pense qu'on
surestime notre notre accessibilité au
public en fait ce que j'ai du coup bruce
a fait moins de vidéos de science ah oui
il ya des raisons ça peut-être par les
matches il n'y a pas du tout évident il
ya plus personne qui joue son rôle j'ai
l'impression en ce moment sur youtube
9en aux manifs et fédé vulgarisation
très très ouverte aussi mais c'était un
os man c'est pas je veux dire j'ai moi
j'ai du mal à mettre d'étiquette science
urnes aux mânes tu vois avec tout le
respect pour son travail que j'aime
beaucoup je trouve ça très fun je suis
étonné quand on le classe dans la
catégorie science tu vois et ça ça
prouve que je suis biaisé en fait parce
que c'est le public qui décide de sa
robe et tu mettrais du coup moins six
ans que bruce carrément way bruce a
quand même fait pour beaucoup d'histoire
des sciences d'après des personnages
clés de l'histoire ça aussi tu vois il
les a rendus swag hilarant du
rock'n'roll et badass comme ils disaient
qu'ils voient et avec alors je sais
qu'il ya eu beaucoup de débats sur bruce
ses méthodes sa façon de faire et c
il n'empêche que en tant que marchepied
vers une compréhension plus comment
dirais-je vert c'est surtout le fait de
s'autoriser je pense autorisés à être
capable de comprendre la science
ouais dans la catégorie bosse on va dire
ça comme ça avec ça il ya peut-être des
gens comme d'artigues logique aussi
cherchent à enrôler
alors là je plaide coupable je
connaissais pas à l'époque en fait ok
mais effectivement effectivement et
d'ailleurs il allait il a les abonnés
qui vont avec quatuor on voit très vite
en fait ceux qui ont ce truc
indescriptible de haies de popularité
quoi
et truc enfin mickey rooney c'était un
petit peu différent mais parce que moi
quand je suis lancé sur youtube de cave
et michael granger lyonnais qui
m'apprenez déjà un peu sept pirates
place très deux matches très accessible
je pense qu'il fait vraiment les maths
les plus accessibles qui est sur youtube
mais il faudra peut-être faire des maths
plus accessible encore que les siennes
notre cas moi j'ai juste dit michael et
dessus du coup j'essaie de pousser un
peu plus loin j'ai c'est de reprendre
déjà les gens qui ont déjà été convertis
par michael on va dire où des gens qui
sont déjà dans les mater ces derniers
plus loin mais tu penses qu'il manque
plus de gens au niveau voire en dessous
de michael fin des trucs un peu plus
brouillon à dire c'est difficile parce
que en même temps tu vois inévitablement
je me demande toujours quand je quand
j'ai vu que ce sujet là est ce qu'on
n'est pas en train de généraliser
est ce qu'il ya pas une infinité de
profil qui est qui qui permettent ce
genre de choses est ce qu'on peut
vraiment isolé ce qui fait le entre
guillemets succès
si c'était le cas je pense que oui
médias produiraient des youtuber à
succès à la chaîne y compris des qui
parle de science et c'est donc après
voilà on a je pense que je suppose que
tu te dis ça aussi souvent un moment
donné tu as ton idéal que tu voudrais
atteindre mais à ce que tu es et tu sais
ce que tu es qui compte le plus c'est
tant pis tutu offre ce que tu as à
offrir et le résultat est issu es tu
t'adaptes en fonction de lui je pense
pas que c'est des trucs qu'ils se
décident mais effectivement dans dans la
galaxie des youtuber il y a il ya ce qui
arriva à rendre ça encore plus
accessible que ce que nous on se
convainc concourant accessible et elle
mène assez mystérieux passé signe chez
une réflexion que j'ai vraiment en ce
moment aux caisses et tim wallach c'est
le moment d'en parler
et qu'est-ce que tu te dis toi par
exemple qu'est-ce que tu te bats ma gens
qui disent que si on te roll c'est pas
vraiment la science est certainement pas
forum ils ont tout à fait raison
et du coup je en train de travailler sur
un autre projet de chaîne qui serait
plus d'accord pour beaucoup sont
beaucoup plus accessibles et sur rendre
en particulier l'informatique et la
science d'informatique et j'ai appelé
l'algorithme est ainsi ressorti ciel
beaucoup plus qu'ils soient gays mais ça
va être un défi assez énorme d'être
c'est un très très gros défi mais j'y
arriverai
après je suis pas d'accord alors for all
peut-être pas faux rôle parce
qu'effectivement moi je suis quand je
regarde les contenus là la partie
mathématiques me perd très vite si je
mets pas la vidéo en pause en tout cas
parce que malheureusement je n'ai pas
été formé aux mathématiques
tiens à le dire j'ai aucune formation
j'ai aucun diplôme je suis vraiment j'ai
tout tout ce qui tout ce qu'il faut pour
penser que c'est un imposteur
mais mais sérieuse quand même c'est
pourquoi c'est parce que parce que tu as
été très philosophique ces derniers
temps qui pensent que tu t'éloignes du
seigneur étrange comme conclusion va
être très fille l'autre et matt et trey
d'accord je parle beaucoup des tic
et puis je ressens je critique beaucoup
la science aussi simple et mes amis la
science d'accord à titre personnel pour
moi ça fait partie de la science tous
ces trucs là maintenant j'imagine que
quand on est à l'intérieur qu'on a suivi
les cursus et c'est qu'on s'est fait
chier avoir un diplôme ou un doctorat
effectivement je peux je peux comprendre
qu'on fasse des catégories beau ce que
ça compte vraiment non je pense à ta
critique le fait sur fait que c'est pas
de la relation ça c'est pas parce
quasiment moi qui le dis quoi donc c'est
pas d'accord c'est pas vraiment une
critique qui met vraiment fait en fait
par contre le problème du forum de dette
de l'accessibilité du contenu en fait ça
c'est un truc qui vous ne me dérange pas
non sens où j'ai pas eu le sentiment que
j'ai l'impression que c'est très
important d'avoir les contenus je pense
qu'elle continue que je fais
tout cas le fond que j'essaie de
communiquer et devrait être plus
communiqué je pense que c'est important
que je les fasse près ça serait encore
mieux si quelqu'un d'autre le faisais du
poids mais je pense qu'il ya besoin de
plus de réflexion sur par donc le degré
de vérité des sciences la méthode
scientifique réfléchir à comment faire
mieux la science différents différents
différentes échelles voilà réfléchir un
peu plus au fondement
et puis parler un peu plus des questions
éthiques
je pense que c'est vraiment des sujets
et puis de des bâtons mieux également
participant à la série red est
maintenant mieux c'est aussi pour ça que
je pense pas pour très science warhol
mais je pense que c'est une des choses
importantes
si si je pouvais renommée ma chaîne tout
en gardant le même à une continuité
je m'en fous un petit peu en fait une
machine cas c'est un peu ça c'est juste
que les contenus je pense que c'est
important acquisitions mais je suis tout
à fait d'accord avec toi sur le fait qu'
il manque aussi de contenu de
l'accessibilité soit guidé la science
ben oui après il faut aussi il ya une
espèce de prémisses qu'on remet jamais
en question si tu veux qu'ils me qui
m'embête toujours dans ces conversations
là c'est est ce que on n'est pas en
train de se dire qu'il existerait une
pédagogie absolue parfaite qui
fonctionne pour tout le monde
est ce que est ce que ce serait pas une
erreur de combat recrée tous avec nous
tu as a way parce que tu peux avoir
plusieurs objectifs qui sont
contradictoires et incompatibles et qui
nécessite effectivement peut-être de
faire deux chez nous ou deux formats
très distincts bien je me vois je vois
aucune légitimité à venir te dire que
mettre des maths sans les expliquer
c'est sans les expliquer pour les
profanes dans mon genre c'est mal mais
je me sens au contraire moi
en nécessité de si je veux comprendre il
faut que je fasse la démarche de mettre
en pause d'analysés etc
donc est ce qu'il ya vraiment une
pédagogie idéal je suis pas je suis pas
convaincu que ça soit je crois qu'il ya
vraiment plusieurs publics et que on va
tous embrasser une partie de ce public
ouais ouais et fois je suis à fait
d'accord avec ça et meiwey en ce moment
je gère un peu une réflexion sur ouais
c'est ça faut aussi bien peu plus j'ai
l'impression et et c'est à fond
important de cibler des gens qui sont
déjà dedans mais qui à mon sens ont
besoin de réfléchir davantage sur
l'épistémologie notamment mais également
cibler un public plus large a cédé à
mener un peu plus vers des relations
situation générale ben c'est une des
questions que tu poses et qui est le
maître dans un autre dans un autre
contexte évidemment mais c'est une
question qui est génial c'est quel est
ton objectif c'est tellement simple et
tellement importante seul cela reposer
régulièrement hockey du coup je vais te
reposer au quai de la pause et
maintenant quel est mon objectif dans
tes vidéos
c'est une bonne question
très franchement c'est simplement le
sait c'est qu'on sait bas je me mets jeu
là vous avec jeanne j'assume ce que
j'avoue là mais c'est c'est le simple
fait d'être utile quoi c'est tout c'est
ça mon objectif c'est j'ai trouvé un
truc dans lequel je suis utile alors je
le fais et en plus de ça ça mène quelque
part et de quelque part étant là
vraiment très bassement le fait de
pouvoir en vivre enfin rang survivre on
va plutôt appeler ça comme ça
évidemment on est très très loin des
canons vendus sur tf1 ou rtl tvi pour
les belges qui est d'ailleurs j'ai passé
kiki inventer des salaires de youtube
heures en rediffusant nos interviews du
crack ce vrai manger prêt à lâcher la
télé belge c'est magnifique
bref
kenny convient d'appréhender les âges il
est alors c'est pas c'est pas une folie
il avait dix mille 700 euros là c'est
pas une fois on n'était pas super loin
mais l'année prochaine au crack ce jeu
compte leur dire que je suis à 15000
euros par mois voilà et alors on s'est
dit qu'avec plusieurs youtuber on a
réfléchi t on aller vers leur balancer
des sommes totalement erreurs voire six
si vérifient leurs infos là c'est je
suis fait d'excellents journalistes
bref petit aparté n'a pas beaucoup de
sens
non mais mon objectif c'est juste ça
après l'objectif par rapport à ce qu'il
ya dans mes vidéos c'est plutôt de
transmettre mon ma réflexion à travers
le temps les gens qui me suivent depuis
le début ce qu'ils aiment bien c'est que
c'est qu'ils voient que ça évolue ça
change je remets en question je reviens
en arrière je corrige toi c'est ce
qu'ils aiment bien sur ma chaise je peux
rien donné d'autre en fait donc rabattu
fait peut-être la compagnie gendre dans
une réflexion qui sait ça c'est une
espèce de soi et c'est un accompagnement
en fait c'est super important france 2
juste d'habituer les gens à avoir une
réflexion et l'avoir à voir l'exemple de
quelqu'un qui réfléchit à comment ils
réfléchissent et c'est très intéressant
et du coup c'est quoi les grands
changements dans tête dentée réflexion
au cours des dernières années mais
malheureusement enfin oui oui non peut
le dire malheureusement c'est évidemment
l'abandon de toute importance légué à
enfin de la sueur importance légué à
l'intuition et au bon sens ont ressenti
ces trucs là qui était un machin que je
pensais affûté au fur et à mesure du
temps mais en fait je m'en rouler dans
un billet au fur et à mesure du temps
tisséo on pense toujours quand les
danses et dans ses croyances là on pense
que les les leaders d'opinion de ce
mouvement là sont ceux qui ont
l'intuition la plus affûtée la plus
subtile qui n'est jamais qu'une
sorte de super pouvoirs en fait mais ça
on n'ose jamais se l'avouer quand et là
dedans on s'imagine que en fait ouais
voilà il y en a qui ont des perceptions
qui dépasse le commun des mortels et
vont devoir abandonner ça c'est très
douloureux parce que c'est un travail de
toute une vie en fait c'est un grand
inconfort de penser que tu laisses
tomber mais évidemment tu trouves tu
trouves d'autres confort de penser alors
là la très très grosse révolution c
c'est tout simplement l'esprit critique
quoi c'est vraiment de se retrouver dans
une position où tu te dis que quoi
quelle que soit l'information qui va
arriver vers toi tu as des outils pour
pour lui donner pour optimiser les
chances de la mettre au plus près de la
meilleure place où elle doit être
je suis très bien et lorsque je dis un
jour j c'est cette idée de
l'optimisation quoi qui soulage
énormément du doute du croyant parce que
pour te prendre un exemple un truc qui
me terrorisait par exemple c'était là
c'était la mort l'idée de la mort g t
j'étais terrifiée par ça j'en avais des
insomnies je me réveille en pleine nuit
avec des sursaut de conscience de
l'inéluctabilité de ma disparition est
en fait le simple fait d'avoir pu me
dire une bonne fois pour toutes que tous
ses espoirs par rapport au budget
expérience magnifique accent anglais
comme tu as changé par rapport aux
halles au delà afin tous et toutes ces
trucs-là pouvoir tout d'un coup les
maîtres non plus dans la case peut-être
vrai mais dans la case il n'y a aucune
raison de penser pour l'instant que
c'est vrai sa masse ça m'a complètement
soulagé de cette angoisse il savoir
placer les choses au bon endroit quoi tu
vois je ne sais pas même si je sais
maintenant que le plus probable de très
très très très loin c'est c'est qu'il
n'y a pas vraiment dame ou de dualisme
eau etc
ça me dérange plus parce que je suis pas
dans le doute
tu vois je suis pas dans le doute
obsédant où j'essaye de prouver une
hypothèse qui me plaît et où je suis à
chaque fois deux doigts d'avoir là
confirmation que ce que je veux qu'il
soit vrai est vrai ça ça rend fou quoi
ça c'est un truc qui rend fou et on s'en
rend pas compte qu'on est dans la
croyance ou tu fais plus gaffe à ce que
tu voudrais croire et à ne pas croiser à
chercher à croire ce que tu voudrais
quoi ce que je voudrais croire je m'en
méfie comme la peste en fait ouais alors
qu'à l'époque c'était la carotte à
j'espère que j'ai raison mais maintenant
je n'espère plus avoir raison ça aussi
c'est un grand changement de plus
espérer avoir raison à ça c'est
clairement un des grands changements
après je veux dire que tu entends alors
mais oui tu as quoi c'est difficile à
appliquer aux pratiques mais mais c'est
vrai que c'est une réflexion nous c'est
souvent moi en ce moment par exemple il
ya enfin mon gros sujets du moment c'est
les titres les ja tuque quart monde à
chaque fois qu'il ya quelque chose qui
donne l'impression que youtube joue un
rôle vraiment important et en
particulier de youtube au fond de moi
j'ai quand même du mal à ne pas me
sentir un petit peu content de voir ça
parce que ça te font les idées que je
défends et tant que cela si j'écrivais
crache dessus du coup ça va faire une
grande de vivre et je sens que j'ai
envie de croire que ça et j'essaie
d'éviter contre 7 en ville c'est certes
à 6 après il ya évidemment un petit vent
de nouveau le danger de la
généralisation
évidemment il ya moi aussi je suis je
suis tout à fait comme ça aussi
regardons un exemple encore plus stupide
va ya voir star wars qui sera en
décembre
j'espère que je vais avoir raison sur ce
que j'ai pensé de ce star wars et de la
sortir c'est con mais voilà là après on
n'est pas dans des trucs qui rendent
malade on n'est pas dans les trucs qui
devient obsédant il est le problème
c'est que les enjeux des grandes
croyances son obsédant la vie après la
mort c'est pas rien c'est pas c'est pas
remporté un petit débat tu vois c'est
pas c'est autre chose c'est d'un autre
niveau
et quand ça atteint des niveaux comme ça
je pense que toi toi non plus tu n'es
plus sensibles tu arrives à maîtriser
cette envie d'avoir raison dès qu'elle
devient obsédante en fait mais en
dessous de l'obsession effectivement
on s'autorise à être content d'avoir
remporté une petite victoire ou des
trucs comme ça
ouais ou être déçu d'avoir d'avoir eu
tort ça c'est certain
c'est de combattre
ben oui je crois qu'on essaie tout
maudit en fait c'est facile et depuis
que tu es sceptiques est-ce qu'il ya
d'autres choses qui t'ont du genre au
cours de la dernière année on va dire
que je sorte à ce qu'ils aient un lien
il ya un point sur lequel tu as fait une
grosse bise à une grosse mise à jour où
tu t'es dit ah oui la grosse mise à jour
c'est de ceux d'avoir quitté quitter ce
[Musique]
scepticisme débutants on va appeler ça
comme ça qui est assez extrémiste
tu sais au début je t'aime je te refais
un peu les classiques 1 mais au début on
découvre les biais on découvre les
sophismes et on se dit ah voilà une
palette d'outils pour avoir la vérité
sans vraiment oser se l'avouer un que
c'est ce qu'on pense en plus un ennui
pendant la vérité c'est la vérité
jusqu'à preuve du contraire on a tout un
tas d'arguments comme ça mais quand on
se lance là dedans la première chose
qu'on découvre c'est c'est exactement
comme une religion cdc des réponses aux
questions et des outils pour répondre et
on en arrive très vite à être ce fameuse
et éthicien hargneux et et imbu de
lui-même qui qui qui redresse les torts
de tout le monde à coups de lattes comme
un argument de machins et là tu fais un
sophisme demi nul
moi je suis je suis plus d'autres 4
l'année qui vient de passer
je suis dans un retour vers vers l'état
de croyance en fait je j'ai une une idée
des signes j'ai l'impression que la
croyance est un ensemble dont la
connaissance n'est qu'une fraction alors
quand on a plutôt tendance à opposer
connaissance et croyances au début j'ai
l'impression que la connaissance est un
sous-ensemble de la croyance au même
titre que les a priori désespoir et c
est donc j'ai envie des plus humbles
j'ai même envie de considérer les
croyants comme des sceptiques et 2d de
penser que les plates east sont devenus
plate east par esprit critique
c'est dur mais c'est ce que je pense de
plus en plus et je pense que en fait
parce que en fait je te dis pourquoi il
ya un détail qui me kyi qui a très fort
indice par rapport à ça c'est que quand
tu vas dans un salon de la voyance ou
que tu discutes entre entre croyants de
x théorie ou même entre croyants d'une
même d'une même religion
il ya immensément de désaccord c'est
très très loin d'être une pensée unique
globale unifiée et c'est dans tous les
secteurs
les théories sur quand on écoute comment
il s'appelle je ne sais plus celui de
thomas a interviewé enfin bon bref un
type qui pensent que toutes les vérités
ce bal et c'est justement quand tu quand
tu écoutes ségala chacun y va de sa
petite théorie elles sont toutes
contradictoires l'une avec l'autre et le
et éthicien débutants et se dit oui sur
trop stupides ils se rendent même pas
compte qu'ils se contredisent entre eux
mais pas du tout ils se rendent compte
qu'ils se contredisent entre mais se
respecte et je pense que là la frontière
qu'on a mis entre croyants et sceptiques
boulot deux mots absolument dégueulasse
qui veulent rien dire en plus il faut la
briser j'aimerais bien qu'on se
rassemble j'aimerais bien que les
j'aimerais bien que les plates east
s'échange nos contenus j'aimerais bien
que les religieux s'échange nos contenus
aussi y trouve des trucs intéressants et
des trucs à critiquer et pareil pour
nous j'aimerais qu'on réussisse à
trouver ce qu'il ya de bon dans leur
contenu à haute voix basse a rejoint d
occupation gueuler sur l'augmentation de
la polarisation
ah bah voila voila d'une poêle ouais
c'est ça c'est qu'on a tendance à se
renfermer chacun dans sa communauté
et puis diaboliser ou caricaturer les
autres communautés
et je pense que c'est un des écueils
récurrents ce qui s'explique par plein
de raisons mais qui effectivement est un
truc à combattre quoi sont des ce sont
des réflexes qui viennent probablement
de l'évolution et ce genre de truc mais
mais mais c'est stupide parce que quand
on creuse et qu'on gratte sous la
surface des mots soulas ou la
signification des concepts ses
frontières elle s'évapore complètement
quoi ça rejoint un peu plus notre
frontière que les gens aiment dont
beaucoup de gens aiment parler c'est la
démarcation entre les sciences et et je
suis pas comment appeler l'autre les
pseudo science où les patients se serait
que beaucoup de gens dont beaucoup
insisté sur cette démarcation monde
l'impression que j'ai maintenant c'est
que le fin du simple fait d'évoquer
cette démarcation est en fait pas très
productif voire en fait même
contre-productive je pense que c'est pas
faux c'est j'ai eu cette discussion avec
jean michel abrassart je pense jean
michel à brassage du dieu du bloc
scepticisme scientifique super blog que
je peux je recommande où il me disait
que lui il a mais pas entendre que une
étude biaisé par exemple sur
l'homéopathie c'était pas de la science
c'est peut-être de la mauvaise science
mais dire que c'est pas de la science
c'est contre-productif et ça m'avait
marqué ce petit argument là j'aimerais
bien le ressortir et l'utiliser à dans
des exemples plus extrême encore tu vois
j'aimerais bien le trouver des limites
parce qu'eux mêmes définir le mot
science tu vois c'est tellement un
bordel et je pense qu'en fait le mot
science
rien que le mot science en fait et dans
la manière dont on utilise souvent
dans beaucoup de débats je trouve que
lui la simple utilisation du mot science
et contreproductive attend c'est un peu
a polarisé chacun ramener chacun sur un
excès de confiance sur ce que chacun
pense avoir compris de la science ou ce
que chacun pense que la science est et
bonjour et ans plus tôt à vouloir parler
d'eux est-ce que ce qu'il est les
théories sont crédibles à quel point
elles sont conformes aux données à quel
point sont justifiables par des préjugés
à quelqu'un du projet sont justifiés ou
justifiable quel point sont crédibles
que exactement c'est un mot qui a été
laissé en jachère au public
je vois des débats sur sur le ring
internationale que qu'on appelle twitter
les gens s'affrontent en dix ans la
science est ce si la science et cela et
bien non les mecs vous êtes simplement
en train de débattre d'un mot pour
lequel vous donnez pas la même
signification donc vous débattez pas
dumas mots ouais et tu vois des justes
des trucs comme ça à prendre le temps de
définir les termes qu'on est en train
d'employés qui est une des bases de
l'entretien épistémique encore une fois
encore une fois on y reviendra peut-être
après c'est tellement vitale tellement
vitale et c'est un pas vers l'autre en
plus habits bien autre côté c'est qu'on
attend ça à utiliser nos propres
définitions
chacun va vouloir imposer sa définition
de ce qu'est la science alors que si on
accepte un peu plus ce fait que chacun
pense à sion différemment ça peut être
utile en fait de réfléchir la définition
de l'autre et utiliser la définition de
l'autre
exactement exactement tout dépend de
l'objectif qu'on a de nouveau canton
quand on entame une échange avec
quelqu'un avec qui on n'est pas d'accord
il faut savoir aussi ce s'avouer quand
on est dans une démarche dogmatique
quand on est en train de se dire mon but
c'est que c'est de prouver que l'autre à
tort et que moi j'ai raison
c'est une démarche dogmatique même si on
a raison elle sera accueillie comme
telle
comme quand nous on n'a que une démarche
dogmatique mais
donc l'on glisse tout doucement des
discussions sur https va tomber c'est je
compte tenter d'apporter ma petite
pierre à cet édifice dans l'année qui
vient
mais justement avec de nouveaux
l'entretien épistémique principalement
puisque c'est le truc dont on parle très
peu sur les réseaux francophones ouais
donc oui je sais c'est un hashtag kim et
qui m'est très cher je pense que c'est
toi qui l'a lancé d'ailleurs c'est moi
qui ai lancé
j'ai beaucoup critiqué récemment ce que
je mets du coup les entretiens piste
éric valentin dit plusieurs fois le
cette expression qu'est ce que c'est
mais alors l'entretien épistémique donc
épistémologie c'est la science de
comment on produit de la connaissance
si je ne me trompe pas contrairement à
une idée reçue ça inclut également
limites et les religions il commet
comment ils sont produits et l'entretien
épistémique c'est donc un entretien dans
lequel on va essayer de comprendre
comment la personne a produit ce qu'elle
pense ce qu'elles affirment
mais ce qui est un exercice extrêmement
délicat très difficile que
personnellement je pense pas encore
avoir réussi pleinement gré il ya un
pionnier à mon sens un pionnier de la
chose qui s'appelle anthony mag magna
bosco qu'on retrouve sur internet
malheureusement en anglais mais il ya
pas mal de vie de ces vidéos qui sont
sous titrées ya même une playlist
francophone avec largage la recommande
huawei c'est assez récent j'ai eu la
chance de doubler un français sur ma
chaîne une de ses vidéos
alors si on sait pas ce que c'est entre
épistémique on va pas on va pas vraiment
comprendre le sens de cette vidéo je
pense c'est plutôt une espèce de
pense-bête de résumé pour ceux qui ont
saisi les grandes lignes de cette
pratique est donc une vidéo avec une
animation on voit que chaque personne a
une tour sur sa tête c'est une
construction mentale de ce qu'on croit
le but de l'entretien épistémique ah oui
alors s'est tous regardés par dans cette
tour est gardé par le prince et la bête
ce qui est amusant il ya la bête qui
abondera faire de
s'arrête s'éterniser dessus la bête
c'est quand on arrive avec un arguments
contradictoires on sort les crocs et
ouais mais toi et toi de toute façon et
on se renvoie la balle et ça sert à rien
c'est complètement stérile et puis le
prince est celui qui va détourner
l'attention qui va faire faire un petit
jeu de boé qui va détourner l'attention
pour pas attaquer la colonne l'entretien
épistémique le but c'est de demander à
la personne simplement pourquoi cette
colonne existe et comment elle l'a mis
en place 1
et pour ça il ya tout un tas de
questions assez intéressantes qui sont
vraiment un peu comme si on était un
élève impertinent si tu veux faut
vraiment se mettre dans la position de
l'élève impertinent face à la personne
si quelqu'un me dit je sais pas moi
l'homéopathie a été prouvé
scientifiquement
je vais lui dire d'abord je vais lui
demander à quel point il en est sûr de
cette affirmation il de meules évalués à
100 % ah bon d'accord bombay comment
est-ce que comment est ce que tu sais
que tu es sûr de ça et perd la personne
va me dire écoute je les ai entendus
dans x vidéo et je les lui dans x
bouquin et puis autant de personnes ne
peuvent pas de son se tromper et là
l'idée ça va être d'extraire la méthode
qu'il apprend qu'il a utilisée pour
produire ça et lui faire comprendre que
cette méthode n est pas fiable dans tous
les cas ainsi essayer de trouver avec
lui
des exemples dans lesquelles cette
méthode en fait elle révèle cette
faiblesse ah bon est ce que tu es sûr
que du coup dès qu'il ya une affirmation
dans des bouquins et dans des vidéos et
que beaucoup de gens les dépenses des
kia ca on peut être sûr que c'est vrai
non pas vraiment et après on va rappeler
à la personne attention parce que tu
étais sûr à 100% au début tu vois et
petit à petit on va on va creuser
creuser creuser creuser sur le comment
il l'a fait pourquoi il l'a fait mais à
aucun moment on va opposer des arguments
à aucun moment on va se poser en tant
que détenteur du notre connaissance on
va rester dans le questionnement et je
pense que pour ça il faut avoir un
un réel amour de la personne à qui on
parle c'est très bisounours like comme
phrase il faut vraiment ne réussirent à
avoir une posture dans laquelle on se
sent pas atteint par les propos de
l'autre qui peuvent être très irritant
ça peut être terrible ça peut être ne
fait pas vacciner tes gosses c'est
épouvantable un truc pareil tu vas à la
crèche chercher ta fille et il y en a un
qui dit ne ferai pas vacciner tu essaies
tu sais que pour optimiser les chances
de faire comprendre à cette personne de
faire douter cette personne il faut
réussir à l'est mais c'est difficile
quoi tu vois et une fois qu'on arrive à
aimer la personne qu'on arrive à se dire
ok si je buvais un verre avec elle je
passerai un bon moment ce qui est je
pense le cas de tout le monde en fait
à ce moment là on peut on peut vraiment
entrer dans une démarche d'entretien
épistémique mais tu pense qu'il faut
d'abord essayer de démêler la personne
avant règle numéro une de l'entretien
épistémique la courtoisie et la
bienveillance
oui d'ailleurs une des astuces de magna
bosco parce que ce ne sont que des
astuces un bon ou pas bon
les idées se bousculent des astuces de
magna bosco ces deux d'abord parler
d'autre chose en fait ah qu'est ce que
vous faites ici ah oui c'est intéressant
va essayer d'avoir une petite
conversation banale pour ressentir ce
lien c'est pas juste pour mettre la
personne en confiance c'est pour soi
ressentir ce lien c'est très important
de ressentir cela moi je commençais un
j'ai une tentative d'entretien
épistémique en vidéo sur ma chaîne qui
s'appelle versus point d'interrogation
la première question que je pose à mon
invité sait toujours comment ça va ça
allait créer aujourd'hui avec ouais
voilà chez eux mais surtout et c'est là
c'est très important quand même parce
que l'entretien piste mx a fait très
manipulation etc
même si on pourrait discuter aussi du du
fait que manipuler ce n'est peut-être
pas spécialement toujours quelque chose
de négatif je pense que quand on dit
merci bonjour etc
on manipule un petit peu aussi quelque
part bon bref je m'égare
l'entretien épistémique si toi tu as
tort tu va très très vite pas rendre
compte ça qui est génial aussi
si l'autre a de bons arguments battus va
très vite se remettre en question c'est
ce qui m'est arrivé par exemple avec des
youtuber les plus décriés de youtube qui
était moutons lucide ou j'ai compris que
derrière ces mots derrière ces concepts
pas toujours si vous n'êtes pas toujours
fiables pas toujours très il y avait un
fond il y avait un message il y avait
une idée qui voulait faire passer il le
faisait avec des méthodes qui qui qui
rendent les sceptiques allergique mais
le fond de son message était intéressant
je la mets bien en fait
mais j'ai réussi à gagner mais tu vois
il ya un message de paix il y avait un
message de jeu je trouve ça pas mal en
fait c'est l'entretien listings m'a
permis ça en fait permis de me rendre
compte que je passe à côté de quelque
chose
ouais avec du coup ça c'est quelque
chose que tu appliques l'entretien qui
suit et des exercices
ouais j'essaye presque quotidiennement
dans les commentaires de ma chaîne j'ai
la chance d'avoir de la contradiction
sous le bras en permanence donc j'essaye
toujours de trouver les petites phrases
tu vois qu'ils vont et qui vont
permettre de retourner la question sur
sur l'évaluation de la méthode qu'on a
utilisées pour produire une affirmation
et et j'ignore complètement le les
attaques les pour qui tu te prends les
machins les trucs c'est important de
après j'ai fait j'ai une facilité c'est
que j'ai été croyant j'ai cru en plein
de trucs j'ai été pédant dans ma
croyance aussi j'étais très agressif
envers les sceptiques dans les années
2000 tout début où j'étais ufologues
donc je vois très bien de l'état dans
lequel on est et j'arrive à passer au
dessus des mots et des attaques verbales
pour ressentir la personne qui est
déstabilisée si tu veux un coup du coup
je le prends moins personnellement c'est
en fait c'est ça qui est très important
c'est de moins prendre personnellement
les choses désagréables mais des astuces
pour y arriver
avoir été croyance à être pas mal mais
si tu sais je sais pas trop je n'ai pas
trop quoi dire ouais ça vaut la peine
d'essayer d'écouté écouter ce qui se
fait de l'autre côté
regardez ces vidéos qui nous iris le
poil alors peut-être pas les plus
éléments mais il ya il ya du bon il ya
du il ya du bon il ya du bon feeling il
ya de bonnes émotions qui ce qui se
passe entre humains il ya de beaux
échanges humains même à base de bullshit
il ya des belles valeurs qui sont
véhiculées il ya de belles valeurs dans
le nouveau testament il ya de belles
valeurs
- elle transcende pas la philosophie
contemporaine mais mais il ya de belles
valeurs quoi une belle valeur un peu
partout réussir à voir le bon et et ce
et transposer ça soit quand quentin
plate east nous assène quelque chose et
qu'on lui répond violemment on n'en veut
pas en fait à sa personne on a
simplement en train de lui renvoyer le
coup qu'on a reçus mais louis
personnellement on ne connaît pas en
fait on s'en fiche
ouais ben quand on reçoit une insulte je
pense qu'il faut aussi se rappeler que
la personne ne nous en veux pas
personnellement pour ce qu'on est
elle renvoie le coups qu'elle a reçus
mais c'est difficile
voilà intégrer tous à en être sûr toi
bats dans la série des bâtons et un
commentaire très récurrent que je reçois
c'est le fait que beaucoup de gens qui
regardent les vidéos du coup pense que
je présuppose que l'interlocuteur est de
bonne foi et c'est mon voeu tout tout ce
que tout se joue tout ce dont je parle
ne s'applique pas d'interlocuteur de
mauvaise foi ce que tu penses que les
entretiens ou systémique c'est simple il
ya des gens de mauvaise foi aussi ça
dépend ce que tu appelles mauvaise foi
si on si on parle de deux personnes près
à toutes les rhétoriques pour s'en
sortir
pour moi c'est pas de la cc de la
mauvaise foi un stress très tôt sensu
comment district au saint suaire sensu
sangsues sinus je cale toujours là
dessus parce qu'il ya consensus mais
stricto sensu
bon bref c'est une forme de mauvaise foi
mais c'est pas du mensonge
moi même je suis je suis malheureusement
devenu extrêmement bon en rhétorique
donc je dois faire très très attention
quand je me dispute dans le quotidien
avec un ami ou même ma compagne je dois
faire très très attention parce que j'ai
la rhétorique facile mais à force
d'avoir pratiqué est ce que pour autant
je suis de mauvaise foi non parce que
quand je m'en rends compte parfois
plusieurs jours après je regrette d'être
tombé dans ce piège là alors on ce genre
de personne n'entretient épistémique
fonctionne parfaitement
simplement ça va être un peu plus long
s'ils vendent le plus éprouvant mais
mais mais y'a aucun souci après si on
parle des escrocs des personnes qui
mentent et qui savent qu'elles mentent
les personnes qui arnaquent
volontairement qu'il reste un fond de
croyance ou pas mais qui qui exploite
vraiment les faiblesses comme pouvait
l'être pauvre tu sais avec son
oreillette qui prétendait entendre la
voix des morts et en fait sa femme lui
dicter les trucs par oreillette parce
qu'il y avait un petit formulaire à
l'entrée de la salle enfin mauvaise
histoire de popol mais ce genre de
personnage entretient épistémique sert à
rien mais parce qu'il va à un moment
donné il va devoir protéger son mensonge
ou le reconnaître et leur bien-être
c'est pratiquement impossible donc je
après il faudra essayer en fait je
t'avoue qu'il n'y a pas d'exemple j'en
sais rien en fait mais j'ai l'impression
gels a priori que ça sert à rien pour ça
que j'ai pas fait avec un certain
certains certaines grandes stars de
l'autre bord on va dire ouais
après jean pelin dire que sur ces
personnes là dans l'intérêt du débat et
il y est limité parce que mes puis je
pense ça correspond à une autre
catégorie de de sceptiques qui est plus
de l'ordre des bunkers et c'est
quelqu'un qui qui malheureusement se
rendre à savent rarement faire la
différence entre un une personne qui
s'embourbe dans sa mauvaise foi
en étant de bonne foi pour ce que ça
veut dire et un authentique escrocs je
le vois bien dans nos groupes on a
tendance à surévaluer la malhonnêteté
des gens mais je pense que ça et ça me
fait rire est tout ce qu on peut faire
réfléchir un petit peu à la manière dont
on se comporte dans plein de débats sur
des sujets qui me tiennent à coeur
ça arrive souvent que 10 un truc qui est
pas tip top et puis après on sent que
notre ego est engagée que du coup on se
sent le besoin de nous défendre
et là on risque d'avoir des arguments un
peu moisie
mais du coup ça arrive à nous aussi il
faut aussi le magazine exactement alors
là je peux dire que ouais moi je les
enchaîne là ça serait les règles du jeu
tu vois moi je moi je personnellement je
choisi d'assumer ça si tu restes j'aime
bien l'idée de l'auto correction c'est
vraiment font date fondamentale pour moi
à titre personnel ça me permet de
libérer ma pensée et ma parole mais
après je m'attends réellement à de la
contradiction
je sais c'est pas des paroles en l'air
quoi je cherche vraiment la
contradiction et je m'attend j'ai
vraiment développé tout un tas de deux
capteurs où je cherche le gars qui va me
contredire de la bonne façon
alors me contredire la bonne façon
comment tu reconnais qu'on te contredis
de la bonne façon parce que ça c'est un
discours déplaisant mais voilà il ya une
structure argumentative qui déjà
respectueuse la plupart du temps qui me
permet de me rendre compte de mes
erreurs et de les corriger
ils naissent ces voix là si tu t'engages
publiquement à à dire des choses tu as
deux chemins soit tu passes un temps
considérable à rendre ça le plus
rigoureux possible et tu te feras très
peu critique et je vais dans certains
formats qui sont très rares soit tu
libères un peu plus ta parole est le but
du jeu c'est justement de la garder en
mouvement de la garder en d'accueillir
la critique et de et d'encaisser le coup
quoi est ce pas si ça fait pas si mal
que ça finalement c'est si on faut
réussir à prendre l'habitude de
d'échangés alors c'est une question
d'habitude c'est vrai ouais c'est vrai
que bon pour ça nous on a de la chance
on a énormément de critiques
donc on peut on peut entraîner son ego à
la recevoir
et puis en plus on est on fait une
oscillation quoi tu vois j'ai remarqué
ça moi j'ai des phases où je vais trop
laid mais comme une brutasse quoi je
vais vraiment à la limite du supportable
avec les commentaires et je vais le
faire à l'excès je vais regretter et je
vais redevenir dans une situation plus
calme où pendant plusieurs mois je vais
être je vais bien virage assez
exemplaire entre guillemets et puis vous
êtes mon ego va reprendre le dessus va
me faire faire des conneries etc
c'est vraiment une oscillation quoi y'a
vraiment je suis sûr si je vous ai une
stat on verra dans quelques courbes bien
corrélé avec des trucs de ma vie c'est
l'été était un peu plus un peu plus
facilement quand je olivères du court ça
j'ai un peu cette idée de il ya
plusieurs versions de moi il ya eu deux
mois maintenant il ya souvent des mois
plus que des aînés moment je suis bien
concentré bien bienveillant oui j'ai
bien mangé j'ai bien dormi
c'est mieux mais aussi des mois moi je
suis plus fatigué et le jeu du mois du
moment c'est aussi c'est de planifier
les moment c'est de faire en sorte que
deux mois du futur sont autant à moi
plus que possible et que quand il sera à
moi moi parce que il sera forcément un
mois - parce qu'il ya des moments où
j'ai faim essayer de faire en sorte
qu'il n'est pas twitter dans les mains
oui c'est ça alors là twitter c'est le
danger absolu
las l'instantanéité c'est terrible mais
est ce que tu es ce que tu pense qu'il
est indispensable de souffrir de nos
attitude regrettable de souffrir c'est à
dire les c'est-à-dire il ya le regret
mais il ya aussi la souffrance que sa
compagne alors moi je suis quelqu'un qui
souffre très très peu
globalement je pense que je pense que
s'il est finalement assez enfin rarement
triste on va dire ça arrive qu'on me
prend une schilthorn je souffre mais en
fait même sa je fais de plus en plus
d'efforts pour et je pense que c'est un
truc qui se travaille beaucoup il ya un
livre que je rencontre beaucoup qui
s'appelle alors fini que j'écoutais la
version anglaise en france sas a été
traduit en suisse cois le titre bref
c'est un livre de thérapie cognitive qui
en fait encourage beaucoup le lecteur à
entraîner et ça se sent ça propre son
propre contrôle sur ses émotions et en
particulier donc moi c'est pas mal
autour du bien-être que donc ils sont
entraînés à être heureux en fait c'est
quelque chose que je pense vraiment ça
s'entraîne quoi il faut il faut le faire
le vouloir aident celles ci ont fait des
exercices on dit je veux être je vais
être heureux
comment on peut prendre l'habitude
d'être plus heureux et al'inverse en
fait la colère si on fait pas gaffe à la
colère c 1,5 c un état émotionnel ultra
addictif
c'est comme si on y réfléchit quand on
est en colère on trouve toutes les
raisons d'être de continuer en colère
oui ça rend vivant ça rend vivant et et
on veut enfin on va dire une raison pour
laquelle on énervé et ça nous énerve si
l'autre ne trouve pas ça énervant aussi
mais on se fâche encore plus quoi qu'ils
disent s'ils essaient de nous calmer on
va s'énerver en dix ans mais si c'est
énervant
et si les énerver ben là ça me d'énerver
encore plus parce qu'on va dire à ma
colère était justifiée c'est vraiment le
raisonnement motiver un demi pour cent
je pense qu'il ya un seuil critique en
fait au delà duquel un emballement est
quasiment impossible
c'est comme ce que voilà c'est le trou
noir quoi il ya un dépassement à la
bombe
il faut que ça pète à mort on va
chercher à ce que ça explose si si on
nous empêche d'exploser mais moi je moi
personnellement cet état là je ne vois
rien d'autre que le mur
pour pour le stopper incapable de
stopper par moi-même sert le mur tu
parles un mur le mur dans le sens je
vais aller trop loin
je pense arriver à l'incident
regrettable as tu penses que tu veux pas
te contrôler c'est là un certain stade
de colère ou jeu où je vais où je vais
avoir besoin d'atteindre la limite en
fait pour m'en rendre compte et revenir
je dois arriver dans le regret pas de
toi il faut atteindre leur gré passez
pas qu'il faut mais c'est que j'ai pas
trouvé d'autre moyen de me contrôler et
c'est trés inconscient en plus je te dis
ça c'est de l'analyse a posteriori mais
j'essaie de contrôler ce sont ces
moments ben va-t-il vivement ces moments
où le téléphone je l'éloignent de moi un
peu qu'il soit dans deux mois j'essaie
de faire autre chose je vais regarder
une vidéo de michael o'neill sagesse je
ne n'arrive pas à avoir ce réflexe là
bas je me force à la regarder doivent
avoir le sourire de michael me cale ou
si on devait faire une balade de soi
mais c'est vraiment le moment où enfin
surtout si c'est un débat qui aura elle
s'est pas sur internet assez c'est le
moment de changer de sujet de se séparer
donc il ya un livre qui est sorti à cinq
s'appellera hotu rave party ball
discussion
je contourne où il parle notamment de sa
et de co ce qu'ils disent et il faut
vraiment conclure la discussion avant de
s'énerver si on sent qu'on va s'énerver
c'est là qu'on dire excusez moi je
fatigue et où il donne l'exclusivité
c'est ça ces actes en salle et se barrer
avant et conclure sur une bonne note
autant que possible oui c'est le fameux
vie en parle d'autre chose de
allez de florent martin qui l'avait dans
une interview sur la chaîne il réussit
réponse fabuleuse je disais alors six
sites à tonton jean marc à table qui te
dis qu'il faut prendre de l'homéopathie
comment tu fais comment tu gères il
m'avait répondu je lui dit viens on
parle d'autre chose
il ya plein de raisons pour lesquelles
je t'aime parlons d'autre chose
ouais je pense que c'est vraiment une
stratégie
en plus quand il fait ça pour le coup il
renoue du lien qui sait ça il rajoute un
truc qui rappelle que ok ça c'est un
point de discorde mais il ya quand même
plein de point de liaison et de nouveau
un tu vois on revient sur cette idée que
les points de liaison c'est ce qu'il ya
de plus important
finalement pour faire quelque chose de
constructif quoi ouais pression sur
sujet de la colère il ya une vidéo de
vie sauce je mens tu as vu il ya une
série minefield de vie sauce hamel est
payant pas non il l'a rendue il ya vendu
maintenant les choix si j'enregistre et
moi qui était gratuite jusqu'à noël que
sont un vrai fond de cale en ce moment
elle est accessible et je la recommande
très vivement et notamment il ya un
épisode en particulier qui est sûre la
colère mais qu'il y ait une expérience
de psychologie ou midi font exprès
d'énerver des sujets donc vous voyez un
des sujets je crois que c'est ils sont
là ils envoient des messages envoyés
suez sont sur un chat et doivent enlever
des messages avec quelqu'un est en fait
de l'autre côté c'est pas une vraie
personne peut mais et de votre côté en
fait ils font exprès d'avoir quelqu'un
qui fait tout pour énerver notamment sa
des trucs raciste tout ce qui énerve
facilement des gens comme une fois que
les gens sont énervés en fait ils les
mettent dans une salade ou à et les
pires façons au hasard county en caisse
si ça tombe sur piles en fait la
personne doit juste s'asseoir dans cette
pièce une pièce avec plein de d'objets
fragiles des trucs d'or des trucs et qui
a à moitié des sujets du coup ils sont
obligés de s'asseoir dans cette pièce
est de regarder la salle et l'autre
moitié ils peuvent ils ont l'ordre de se
défouler qu'on leur donne
oui leur donne des marteaux et tout ça
et paf ils doivent tous défoncés et
ensuite il re donc les sujets ensuite
reviennent dans une fois un jeu ensuite
les suivants un jeu avec lui il pense
que c'est avec la personne avec qui ils
ont eu le cateau des bucs et c'est un
jeu wii
il faut taper le plus qu avant l'autre
en fait il ya un signal qu'il faut
appuyer sur un bouton juste avant aussi
vite que possible et si on arrive à
appuyer avant que l'autre mois sachant
qu'ils aient pas d'autre mais l'autre
appuyez sur le bouton et ben on peut lui
mettre du fer nous donner une décharge
électrique
surtout on peut régler la puissance de
cette décharge électrique
d'accord d'accord d'accord mais skient 6
observe assez clairement dans la vidéo
c'est que je crois qu'ils allaient ra
pas beaucoup de sujet on apprend du
scientifique ça mais enfin c'était assez
net c'est que les personnes qui ont su
rester calme dans la salle
qui donc ou non pas une colère qui s'est
défoulé ces gens là étaient beaucoup
plus gentils et même dans la manière de
jouer enfin limite ils rigolaient quand
on jouait à terrassement voilà ils
mettaient de toute petite décharge alors
que les mecs qui s'était défoulé juste
avant et il m'était truc à fond
directement puis au moment de jouer ici
et là tu y apprendre ça
elle était vraiment peur oui mais je
vois alors je veux pas la ramener avec
star wars mais yoda avez raison quoi la
colère et la colère tu vois c'est un
truc que tu vois très fort quand tu es
quand tu es jeune parent c'est que bon
tu dois 4d ton calme face à un être qui
ne comprend absolument rien de ce que tu
peux lui dire ou lui envoyer comme
signaux est clairement les nuits les
plus supportable sont celles où tu
gardes ton self control ouais et les
nuits les plus insupportables sont
celles où tu lâches la pression et ce
concept de lâcher la pression c'est
c'est un billet complet quoi parce qu'en
fait c'est augmenter la pression qu'on
finirait c'est assez fou l'impression
qu'il faudrait se soulager de cette
colère etc
alors bon je dis pas un parfois parfois
ça peut être nécessaire mais ça peut
s'exprimer
autre façon comme tu le disais allez
faire une balade se dépenser tapez dans
un coude shing bollmann et après être
soulagé hier mais le fait de lâcher la
pression face à l'adversaire face à
celui qu'on a identifié comme adversaire
pardon ça c'est pas du tout une bonne
chose
dans l'épisode aussi un moment où il
juste on se défoule sur un punching-ball
patients petit paumé sur un boxeur mais
bon tant que ça vu la puissance physique
de viçosa apparemment c'est comme si un
petit bol vote égal le boxeur a pas
beaucoup bougé et en fait ce qu'ils s
est notamment le logo boxeur ce qu'ils
disaient c'est que vous faites quand tu
fais ça dans un cadre sportif tu en fais
tu te concentres vraiment sur le sport
lui-même mais fait de donner des bons
coups de alors que quand tu casses ta
vaisselle
parce que tu énervé en fait tu penses
que tu vas tu penses pas est-ce que je
casse bien ma vaisselle tu penses
vraiment un truc qui t'énerve est en
fait ces empires l'autre donc c'est vrai
c'est ça c'est le fait de focaliser son
cette énergie on peut voir ça comme ça
sur un truc précis en fait ça fait qu'on
l'a conscientisent déjà on la rend plus
légitime m'ont l'estiment comme quelque
chose à évacuer c'est déjà tout un
travail psychologique en fait tu vois je
vois bien attention c'est pas mal mais
minefield un truc que je veux rattraper
mais heureusement j'ai pas tu pas encore
lancé dedans mais je qu'en dit en
parlant de débat récemment tu as fait
une vie s'il est au départ était de
colère on va dire de dénervaud
d'agacement tu as fait une vidéo
récemment sur etienne qu'un qui
interview stéphane foucart mais a dit
avoir regretté certains trucs de cette
vidéo est ce que tu peux en parler un
peu plus déjà du contenu de la vidéo et
puis ensuite
alors bon il ya tout un contexte assez
tout un contexte qui compte même si même
si au final ce sont des excuses entre
guillemets le contexte c'est la
réapparition d'un format qui est très
important pour la chaîne qui est le
petit point d'intérêt
sion qui est une espèce de vlog un truc
que je sais le en fait le but de ce
format c'est simplement de pouvoir
sortir un truc rapidement seulement je
suis probablement comme comme toi et
comme de nombreux vulgarisateur dès que
je commence je sais quand je commence
mais je sais pas quand je m'arrête
s'apprend très très vite des proportions
je finis par me dire non en fait ce
sujet j'aurais dû en faire une vidéo
sérieuse et le cas de stéphane foucart
mérite vraiment une vidéo sérieuse parce
que c'est tellement subtil c'est
tellement faim donc il ya eu j'ai
commencé ce format en janvier je
l'aimais interrompues en mars je pense
je commence un soir en décembre gelé
interrompues en mars et stéphane foucart
est très vite revenu régulièrement dans
les colonnes à cause de ce qu'il dit sur
le glyphosate principalement et au début
je me faisais simplement l'écho de deux
copains sceptiques en qui j'ai confiance
sur le point de l'être au niveau de la
méthode principalement bunker 10 pour ce
qui est du glyphosate et donc et un
mondrian aussi et je viens pas de tous
et enroule envoyé un message secret un
vrai tout est petit à petit se sont
posés des interrogations sur stéphane
foucart je me suis dit mais comment
c'est possible qu'on en arrive à ce
qu'ils veulent idée que j'en avais en
fait elle n'était pas réaliste l'idée
d'un journaliste qui parle de science
n'importe comment et qui est au journal
le monde comme sa grande importance
c'est idéal
elle tenait pas la route il y avait un
bug quelque part le bug était de notre
côté est ce que le bug était de son côté
avec j'enquête là dessus bien plus tard
dans l'année quand j'ai mis le petit
point en pause je me suis renseigné sur
roger j'ai eu je passe très très vite
les détails j'ai eu un harceleur avec
qui je suis en procédure
même s'il ne s'est pas encore enfin bon
bref j'ai eu à arcelor qui m'a vraiment
attaqué en pensant que j'étais payé par
monsanto etc et je me suis dit bon allez
on va un petit peu regarder d'où vient
cette idée qu'il ya des gens qui sont
payés par monsanto et je suis tombé sur
un truc absolument extraordinaire bon
alors je le cite comme ça sans
ressources et sans appui mais la plupart
des en fait il ya deux sources
principales à cette idée qu'il ya des
gens qui sont payés par monsanto
la première source et l'association des
victimes de monsanto qui sont qui est
aux etats unis c'est un groupe d'avocats
qui défend les victimes
bon ça n'en fait pas une source de
premier choix on va dire une source très
impliqué émotionnellement et c est dans
un combat légal bon ben voilà le
juridique s'est pas vraiment de la
zététique est la deuxième source et là
ça m'a surpris sur le plan intérieur et
international
c'est la relecture de stéphane foucart
des monsanto peppers mais monsanto
peppers ans élite est justement tout ça
je me dis parfait bon je m'abonne au
journal le monde
je lis tous les articles de faux garé
sur le sujet et je ne trouve à aucun
moment un passage où il où il donne la
source versement sans topper je me dis
bon sens c'est incroyable ce gars à une
telle autorité
on sait partager cette idée qu'il ya des
trolls de monsanto même nous en fait on
l'a acceptée une pratiquement sur base
de ce que lui a relu des monsanto
peppers jeu
je devrai pour pour vraiment m'en tenir
au fait je devrais lire cesser ces
centaines de milliers de pages
j'exagère un peu je te relire ces
milliers de pages pour pour savoir d'où
vient cette idée là et quand j'ai creusé
un petit peu j'ai pas trouvé la même
interprétation si tu veux donc je me
suis est en souffrance à quelque part à
cause de ce que fout car en a dit
puisque j'ai un harceleur
j'étais en colère contre lui même et
quand j'ai découvert qu'il allait chez
thierry klein way qui est une de
personnes à qui je dois le plus j'ai
perdu j'ai perdu complètement mon sang
froid et je me suis dit ah ben voilà ça
c'est parfait pour mon blog élevé je
vais faire un coup de gueule comme comme
tous les blogueurs font alors le matin
je me dis allez je vais m'infliger déjà
j'utilise ce terme je vais m'infliger
cet épisode de la conversation
scientifique ou foucart et là et je vais
en faire une réaction à chaud je vais
l'assumer comme tel y aura pas de
problème ouais bon bah c'était un peu se
condamner à regretter ce qu'on fait
marquer dans ce match c'est la foi qui
fait ça ben voila je fais un truc sur
lequel tu sais qu'il sera à wayne on l'a
clairement ce n'était pas du tout une
bonne idée je crois que la prochaine
fois que je réagirais la chose ne sera
sur un truc subjectif commune
artistique ou ou là je pense que c'est
légitime mais mais là je me suis
amèrement votre et donc il se trouve que
le fond de cette vidéo je ne le regrette
pas parce que je continue de penser que
que stéphane foucart n'avait pas sa
place dans cette émission ça c'est mon
opinion pas c'est très discutable mais
c'est mon opinion je pense qu'il ya un
niveau si tu veux où je pense que là
elle parle à la conversation
scientifique pour marc représente un
argument d'autorité scientifique assez
assez fort assez dense je pense que si
on invite quelqu'un là dedans il ne doit
pas avoir ce niveau là de contradictions
donc voilà c'est mon idée à moi que je
me fais de cette émission c'est
manifestement pas celle que ce que santé
etienne klein j'ai raté une belle
occasion aussi de faire une réelle
analyse de stéphane foucart qui était un
truc que je voulais faire depuis
longtemps et j'ai raté une belle
occasion de présenter des beaux
arguments je fais un magnifique homme de
paille c'est à dire que je je déforme
les propos de stéphane foucart jeu les
exagère pour mieux attaquer ce que ce
que ce que j'avais envie d'attaquer et
bref c'est un échec total cette vidéo
donc voilà qu'est ce qu'on peut qu est
ce qu on peut faire derrière ça je me
suis dit je vais la supprimer mais pile
au moment je me suis dit est ce que je
la supprime ou pas etienne klein a leaké
intuit qui disait à j'espère que tu vas
pas supprimé la vidéo quand même ike a
indiqué white
c'est le seul truc qu'il a leaké de tout
de tout ce qui a été formatrice que je
guettais moi évidemment mais qu'en
pense-t-il bon sens réagi dis moi
quelque chose ce qu'il ne fera pas
évidemment il est bien trop malin pour
ça enfin malin dans le bon sens et il ya
juste cet indice là je me suis dit merde
puis j'ai aussi bon ben oui si ça se
trouve en fait c'est juste 5 la
contradiction existe quelque part
donc je vais la laisser je vais
l'assumer mais je vais je vais en
reparler puis c'est après tout c'est
tout l'intérêt d'un blog c'est pouvoir
garder cette réflexion en mouvement
permanent et voilà après il ya eu le
groupe jp vernant qui s'en est mêlée qui
a considéré cela comme une vidéo de
vulgarisation qui se voulait
c'est vrai qu'ils lui même fait un homme
de paille sur mon homme de paille alors
ça a été tout un clash twitter est comme
seul twitter en en chocolat est riche
je passe les détails sur cet épisode là
qui était pas très intéressant mais qui
était quand même amusant et jp verdin
défendu fou car c'est juste critique et
avignon alors c'était assez nébuleux je
pense qu'il défend fou car quand je le
camp joly
je vois qu'ils attribuaient à foucart en
tout cas qui ne m'attribue pas le droit
de critiquer fouquin ce qui n'est pas
étonnant de la part de jp berne en mai
mais j'ai pas vu de 2,2 de support
intégral de ce que foccart disais non je
pense l'avoir vu quand même être honnête
mais il mail me dégommait vachement est
de nouveau pour le coup là c'était du
gros homme de paille très visible c'est
un peu dommage parce que du coup ça ça a
donné un à priori à ceux qui ont ensuite
été voir la vidéo et qui sont passés
complètement à côté de toutes les
petites phrases que je dis qu'ils sont
importantes pour moi j'aimerais
comprendre je veux comme contredisent
etc qui peuvent passer pour des
arguments rhétorique qui sert juste à se
protéger mais qui mois pour moi sont
réellement important je cherchais
vraiment la contradiction des reçus pour
le coup mais pas d'où je veux pas d'où
je m'y attendais pas de la façon dont je
m'y attendais c'est important ce que tu
dis sur le fait de espèce de prémy
effect essai de l'état dans lequel on a
priori que tu as au moment de soi
écouter une émission soit regardé une
vidéo youtube même dire détruites
ses influences énormément la manière
tout analyser tous personnellement les
choses c'est ce que et c'est ce que j'ai
eue pour la conversation scientifique le
simple fait de savoir que foucart était
dedans biaisé complètement mon jugement
que ses missions si je l'avais écouté
sans savoir que c'était lui
qu'est-ce que je me serais dit ouais ça
c'est une question intéressante aussi tu
vois c'est
là c'est je pense que c'est vraiment un
truc sans qu'elle fêtera ses rangs pas
facile je sais que typique bon port ce
matin on m'avait envoyé un truc sur le
une défense du frais kantisme mais ça
quand j'ai ouvert la page
il ya forcément à fx quelque part en moi
qui dit or qu'est ce qui est faux ben
oui bien sûr évidemment tous ses papiers
pas pas justifié c'est justifié de
penser qu' il ya quelque chose qui va
pas bon on sait ce qu'on a priori mais
par contre ce qui est problématique
c'est que ça met dans un état d'esprit
où je suis là pour critiquer bah oui et
si les trucs bien ben je vais passer à
travers
c'est assez difficile l'entretien beast
et mick permet d'éviter ça quand il est
bien pratique et mais tu peux pas avoir
un entretien épistémique avec un article
ou avec une vidéo
donc c'est très difficile de soi même se
dire bon allez je vais aimer même
stéphane fouks le journal le monde
c'est parti je me lance alors je dis pas
que j'aime pas le journal le monde c'est
parce que je veux dire je vais aimer je
vais me mettre dans cette posture ou g
où je les ai même j'imagine qu'ils sont
bien faisant équipe ans d'affaires c'est
un sens c'est presque impossible
ouais ça m'arrive souvent d'arrêter il
ya plusieurs podcast que j'ai commencé
j'ai pas réussi à définir parce que away
web a concédé mal
après on est humain aussi tu vois je
pense qu'il ya un seuil où je pense qu'à
partir du moment où moi je moi je par
exemple je je te vois très exigeant
envers toi même à un niveau d'exigence
qui personnellement je le range presque
dans la catégorie u topie si tu veux ça
me semble personnellement inatteignable
ce que toi tu essayes de faire avec toi
même j'ai moi je suis plus j'ai plus
tendance à accepter le fait que je vais
garder des défauts je vais garder des
torts et et que je pourrai pas y faire
grand chose au final à part toujours
tendre vers un mieux alors est ce que
c'est parce que toi tu es beaucoup plus
loin que moi dans
dans la réflexion et que tu en est
carrément à attendre de toit des
améliorations que moi je perçois même
pas pouvoir exiger de moi même je sais
pas répondre à cette question mais en
tout cas voilà un bon c'est pour ça que
je te pose la question tout à l'heure
est ce que tu en souffrent n'oublions
pas d'accepter de commencer par accepter
ce qu'on est et qui on est quoi si je
peux dire un truc aux internautes qui
nous écoutent non mais c'est ici que
j'ai c'est d'être très exigeant avec moi
même
mais c'est aussi parce que les gens
souffrent pas c'est un des points très
bas voilà important c'est que j'ai
l'impression d'avoir beaucoup progressé
en cours d'année et en fait je trouve ça
vraiment fan passé c'est julio il ya des
mois j'ai des limites ravagé où il ya
souvent sur malysz de podcasts il ya
cinq-six d'un podcast que j'ai arrêté
j'arrive pas à les continuer parce que
je suis trop en désaccord avec personne
qui parlait mais est-ce qu'on a droit
des exemples où s class s sas à avoir
avec la sécurité de l'ira adacore way to
kill yahya yahya ce débat à ce que lier
avec dangereuse et est ce que elle sera
dangereuse tant que futur accord
et moi je pense qu'on sous estime
beaucoup les dangers d'un déjà de l'ia
de youtube que je pense qu'on sous
estime aussi beaucoup la complexité à la
capacité de surveiller nyha ii you tube
et du coup quand il ya des chercheurs
ultra reconnu et réputé qui sont là à
dire dans mes liens on sait comment ça
fonctionne on contrôle tout ça peut pas
de danger on pourra des branches et si
un problème c'est le genre de truc qui
me hérisse le poil parce que des
branches et youtube aujourd'hui
bah non non non bien sûr que non ouais
se laisser la place à pierre en plus
donc assez c'est exactement ça et je
pense que c'est un problème très très
compliqué et minimiser la difficulté du
problème
ça ralentit la recherche sur les
solutions pour le problème et faire
progresser des enjeux à l'échelle de
l'humanité
ça me hérisse le poil quand les cours
les gens dénigrent la difficulté des
rangs désir bénéfique
oui un peu trop de scientisme dans tout
ça à ton bâton sens qu'il ya une
confiance aveugle il ya il ya un peu
trop de confiance aveugle et puis il ya
un manque de projection assez énorme je
pense
on parle beaucoup des fois j'ai
l'impression que c'est beaucoup de gens
parlent d iliad ya trois ans où il ya
cinq ans oui alors que moi ce qui me
fait peur c'est un dia les ja
d'aujourd'hui me paraissent préoccupante
et ce qu'ils font qu'amplifier les iad
dans cinq ans dans dix ans dans 20 ans
alors je précise quand même parce que je
vais je vais faut regarder ça sûr sûr
sûr mais réseau quand on parle dit là on
parle pas d'une entité pensante est
consciente qui qui pourrait tout d'un
coup vouloir contrôler le monde on parle
ça c'est plutôt le concept dia forte tu
m'arrête si je me trompe et qu'il en
mais nulle part en fait aujourd'hui ça
c'est un truc qu'on annonce même ce
discours je trouve ça parce que il y a
je pense qu'on a tendance à faire une
distinction assez nette entre ya forte
et leaf qui a ce qu'on appelle faible
parfois ouais alors que si on réfléchit
à l'ia de youtube aujourd'hui elle fait
des choses qu'aucun humain est capable
de faire par exemple par les gars de 500
heures de vidéo par minute et elle doit
faire ça parce que il ya de la
modération à faire sur youtube et bien
sûr et c'est très important de faire
parce que des vidéos de meurtre qui sont
mises en ligne quoi il faut qu'elle soit
censuré du coup il ya vraiment un
travail à faire et c'est ya en plus
c'est ultra sophistiqué c'est vraiment
tout ce qui se fait de mieux aujourd'hui
on n'y a donc elle fait de la regarde la
vidéo vraiment a fait la perception
reconnaissent ils capables de rock indé
visage je pense qu à cécilia 30 dans une
vidéo cette seule ça c'est classe cas ne
sait pas ce qu'elle est ce qu'elle
comprend le s quel effet de normandin
c'est ça a fait du sous titrage
automatique des vidéos
elle va faire la traduction automatisée
des sous titres et aujourd'hui enfin ça
c'est un domaine qui entendent eux qui a
expliqué ca capacité à extraire parle de
représentation sémantique mais
espèce de sens une représentation
abstraite de message important de vidéos
je pense que typiquement a passé
facilement dire si elle peut facilement
dire si le mot nazi a été utilisé dans
une vidéo mais elle est même capable de
savoir si il a été utilisé de manière
purement comique ou si ça a été utilisé
pour défendre les idées nazies et il ya
beaucoup de recherches qui vont de plus
en plus dans cette direction
et voilà je pense que il va y avoir des
progrès assez énorme dans les années à
venir et semble capable de comprendre
aussi des trucs que moi je serais pas
capable de comprendre en regardant une
vidéo
parce que elle est capable de connaître
tout un contexte qui avait motivé très
complexe et il ya des communautés sur
youtube que je n'imagine même pas situer
et qui ont leur façon de parler que je
ne comprends pas mais il ya de youtube a
regardé plusieurs des vidéos de cette
communauté dont il y avait peut-être
capable de comprendre des choses que je
ne suis pas capable de comprendre et
donc en fait on demande à une
intelligence artificielle d'atteindre
des objectifs pour lesquels elle a une
connaissance qui nous dépasse mais ça
c'est effectivement assez dangereux et à
un pouvoir c'est énorme mais ça c'est le
côté un peu sophistiqué
elle a aussi tout en 8 août on
historique youtube du coup c'est tout
ego qui et quels sont les contenus qui
est qui qui sont addictifs pour toi quel
genre de contenu une fois que tu as
cliquez dessus passe peut-être trois
heures à regarder le même genre de
contenu
alors je ne sais pas je suis chez toi
c'est le cas mais chez moi
les recommandations youtube c'est pas
encore ça c'est souvent un peu la misère
quoi je suis un petit peu
j'ai un petit peu déçu moi de cette
partie el adli a en tout cas pour moi
j'ai aussi interagir avec ses tirs dans
le sens où il ya des contenus je lui ai
dit j'ai pas envie de voir ça ouais du
coup elle s'est vraiment go on y aille
sur mesure maintenant et elle me montre
vraiment ce à quoi j'ai envie d'être
exposés ah oui d'accord j'ai toujours
peur d'utiliser ce bouton parce que des
fois je me dis mais elle va pas
comprendre pourquoi je veux pas voir ça
voilà des fois j'ai envie de lui dire je
veux pas voir ça mais c'est parce que je
les ai déjà vus avec ça c'est un petit
peu plus compliqué à communiquer et ça
que c'est un débat aussi c'est qu'on
peut pas très bien communiquer avec ses
7 il ya du cerveau nerfs on peut juste
dire une vidéo qu'a l'a proposé si on
veut y être exposé enfin de plus en
souvent parti si on veut ne plus être
exposé à cette vidéo sans doute moyen de
faire des meilleurs d'enfin moi c'était
les vidéos de foot notamment chercher un
peu c'est une addiction que et j'ai
demandé à l'oea de youtube chaque fois
que je vois une vidéo de foot tu disais
à de me proposer ça et j'étais pas
capable non plus de lui dire que j'ai
pas envie que tu me proposes ça parce
que j'aime pas mais c'est parce que ces
contenus addictif mais bon je pense
qu'elle a deviné je vois donc un petit
peu plus interagir avec cette dangereuse
et qu'elle est très influente passé ce
que nous on a parlé pas mal de la
production de contenu taxe est assez
accessible tout ça mais je redirai des
vidéos d'y penser à son sur youtube et
idiot youtube a un pouvoir énorme cercle
est qu'elle soit l'expérience
l'admiration de la science que tu as
connu via bosses maelle poids peut être
appliquée à milliers des centaines de
milliers peut-être de personnes voire
des millions de francophones en tout cas
on recommande davantage les vidéos de
brousse à des personnes qui sont pile
dans la phase où ils ont besoin ils
gagneraient beaucoup à techs prise à ce
jour de contenu
oui c'est vrai après je je je le sais de
troisième main chez youtube ils ont ils
sont très attachés à l'idée d' humaniser
youtube
j'ai un ami qui est la silicon valley
qui travaille avec la maman de l'insigne
youtube comme ça tu pas tous les jours
et mme expliqué que vraiment la laci you
dont le nom est imprononçable pour moi
je vais pas me risquer à sa sézanne
qu'elle est qu'elle est très attachée à
l'idée d' humaniser youtube et notamment
de tu sais il ya eu toute cette vague ou
youtube design il allait essayer de
limiter la visibilité des contenus
conspi alors tout le monde a dit c'est à
cause des annonceurs c'est pas tout à
fait vrai c'est aussi parce que chez
youtube c'est pas des c'est pas le
diable qui est en creux et oncle picsou
qui veulent absolument de l'argent c'est
aussi des gens qui veulent humaniser un
peu leur plateforme par exemple ils ont
fait un truc à vérifier si ça fonctionne
sur le réseau francophone
c'était l'exemple que mon ami me disait
une des études tape des recherches pour
qui ont trait au suicide
comment comment bien suicidé et bien en
premier résultat tu vas avoir plutôt des
vidéos qui veulent venir en aide aux
gens suicidaire quoi les chaînes youtube
c'était extrêmement fier de ça même si
c'est de la petite gloriole là on peut
on peut dire c'est pas assez et ses
veaux moi je suis plutôt dans la
démarche de don corrigé de féliciter
même si évidemment youtube ne m'écoute
pas voilà il ya une volonté d'humaniser
il ya une volonté d'aller vers un mieux
et surtout de d'injecter une éthique
dans cette ia alors après c'est
évidemment très très risqué mais ça
casse quand même l'image de l'eee en
roue libre qui qui va nous laisser tous
dans le but cognitive et c'est quoi ton
gré c'était en est après sept ans cette
année 2009 condé 18 c'était un papa un
petit moment quand même je dirais je
dois fin 2018 mais parce que je pense
qu'il ya un shift partir de 2017
enfin hambourg aux suites à cambridge en
éthique et tout ça j'ai l'impression que
les facebook youtube google tout ça et
plus éthique maintenant ces entreprises
les ingénieurs demande plus éthiques
notamment
ouais ils sont des humains qui bosse là
dedans donc ils ont pas envie d'être les
méchants quoi c'est un truc qu'on oublie
toujours quand on l a stigmatisé les
stigmatise mail à associer
systématiquement les gaffes âme au
diable à des gens qui ne pensent qu'aux
profits etc ou même les riches tout
simplement les associés c'est riche
c'est devenu synonyme de malfaisants
pour pour la plupart des gens tant il ya
bien des riches qui sont extrêmement
philanthrope voire même des personnes
riches sans qui certains progrès
n'aurait jamais existé parce que parce
qu'aucun gouvernement de se relancer
cuire space x quel gouvernement allait
se lancer dans un truc pareil
aucun tu vois et voilà donc c'est un
petit peu présidente de diabolisation
comme ça des gars femmes des personnes
riches c'est un truc aussi contre
laquelle je lutte sans vouloir non plus
les blanchir systématiquement par là
mais ça reste des humains comme tout le
monde il ya des gens qu'ils aiment dans
leur quotidien ils n'ont pas envie que
les gens qui a qu'ils aiment ils leur
arrivent des bourdes et s'ils sont
responsables de ces bourdes ça les
emmerde autant que n'importe qui donc gg
je suis relativement optimiste par
rapport aux tentatives et à la volonté
de bien faire
après je rejoins un petit peton
pessimisme ou en tout cas tu as méfiance
par rapport à la trop grande confiance
qu'on peut accorder aux progrès qui se
passe actuellement ou en tout cas sont
inquiétantes absence des débats publics
au niveau de la population j'entends pas
au niveau des niveaux des instances etc
ouais rien documentaire en ce moment que
j'ai commencé à regarder sur netflix sur
bill gates oui oui mais moins bien son
âge est assez fascinant qui passe
vraiment pour le diable en france
exactement alors que ce soit d'un point
de vue entropie il fait quand même des
trucs
c'est grâce à ce sacré le son ou
récemment l'animateur je sais plus quand
il s'appelle à g de mémoire atrocement
un animateur de talk-show super connu
avec des lunettes là qui toujours très
drôle et il a décidé de racheter des
dettes médicale ouais et il a créé une
société de rachat de dettes médical
c'est à dire c'est une société qui
négocie un ensemble d'être médical pour
les racheter à un prix plus bas
c'est extraordinaire alors lui a demandé
pourquoi vous avez fait ça il a répondu
parce que je le peux et je pense qu'il
ya vraiment peu poussé aussi loin c'est
aussi une question de jean säntis qu'on
met à ces gens là que si à chaque fois
que quelqu'un fait un truc un peu un peu
philanthrope on initie sprint shipstern
parce que ce qu'ils peuvent a aussi
juste ne rien faire écrit de risque
défini store des faibles ont mené des
mauvaises saint-yzan donne pas envier à
ces gens de mon essayer c'est exactement
gmail j'imagine à peine qu'elle lutte ça
doit être comme bill gates quoi le
nombre de critiques qu'il a dû affronter
pour m pour mettre ça en place le nombre
de gens d'amis de proches de l'être de
courriers de fans
ça va être ça doit être terrible by par
billy j'aime maintenant l'appeler mon
collègue william parce que je sais pas
si tu sais il a une chaîne youtube par
bon et il fait des vidéos de youtube
heures qu'il ya des vidéos par l'onf et
scame expliqué un truc et ça fait très
vieux tubes là où va sur le terrain et
budget un peu différent de ce marasme
mais ces désagréments il y en a une
parce que en fait donc c'est bon c'est
mieux que je fréquente un petit peu pas
beaucoup mais un petit peu les pointes
de l'action humanitaire à grande échelle
pour aider les pauvres ça c'est des
milieux où
il ya bien des gros bonnets qu'un des
goulots d'étranglement le truc qui
permettrait de faire que ça va beaucoup
mieux
c'est souvent des problèmes
d'information nous par exemple on pense
à la santé mondiale
grosse partie de la santé mondiale a à
voir avec l'information parfois des
trucs tout tout tout bête que comment
mettre une moustiquaire par exemple ça a
un impact assez est donc ainsi à des
solutions pour juste améliorer même
légèrement la qualité de l'eau autant
dans les pays en voie développement
je pensais quand ça va vraiment énorme
juste connaître qui est des problèmes de
vaccinations savoir où est-ce qu'ils
allaient pointe de vaccination quand il
est plein d'informations assez assez
énorme et du coup motiver des gens pour
distribuer les vaccins au bon endroit et
pays de développement ça c'est si des
preuves d'informations assez énorme et
clairement si les problèmes que bill
gates que nos collègues williams a
rencontré mon collègue que cio youtuber
aussi que d'accord mais pourquoi
williams parce qu'il s'appelle william
bill ses revenus
c'est alors les mecs qui s'appelle bill
c'est toujours des diminutifs de trucs
chelous un jet bassement williams ok
d'accord complexe guilde préfère au
collègue il relève un autre collègue à
saint patron c'est un collègue est
ouverte en mai youtube et youtube c'est
le même patron c'est donc notre collègue
bilba lui ici rendu compte qu'ils ont
des gros problèmes c'est avec l'idée
informations et louis produit des
contenus comme des youtuber je trouve ça
assez morne dire que le mec le plus que
des mecs les plus puissants à des mecs
les plus riches en tout cas du monde qui
passe une bonne partie de son temps à
faire des trucs comme ça c'est cool ça
veut ça veut dire que les mecs dans deux
des types de sons de sens de son niveau
se disent que c'est un des très bons
moyens pour faire bouger les lignes ça
on n'est pas si bête en fait à
s'acharner sur youtube avec nos stats et
le machin c'est vraiment ça c'est un mec
est qui et qui littéralement son temps
je suis pas une journée pour lui ça
coûte un million quoi c'est un oubli
c'est sûr du coup il met des millions
indirectement avec sa personne ils sont
aussi plus ou moins directement à juste
produire des vidéos youtube comme toi et
moi que il veut seulement que je regarde
sa finale et surtout sachant qu'ils
optimisent tout cas dire dans les
commentaires
c'est dire la valeur qu'il attache à
créer des contenus youtube que nous
avons vraiment la peine d'aller les voir
alors et donc si des gens qui pensent
que c'est effectivement important qui
est aidée financièrement des gens qui
essaient de faire comme bill
oui mais oui c'est vrai mais je parle
pour moi oui bah après tu vois il ya
toujours moi je trouve qu'il ya un truc
qui est un petit peu dommage c'est que
on associe l'optimisation d'une chaîne
au fait qu'elle va qu'elle va rendre la
fin ça va ça va nous permettre d'en
vivre si tu veux et je trouve qu'il ya
pas assez de je trouve que l'apport le
plus important ce serait plutôt de ddd
youtuber qui ont un très bon contenu
mais à le rendre plus incertaine ma
voiture mais j'ai un gros regret
justement que des puits de connaissances
comme qui comme ce qu'on peut trouver
sur ce chercheur wedia par rapport au
rapport à youtube ne
n'aide pas les youtuber qui ont un bon
contenu à l'europe voit même si c'est
des tout-petits youtuber ainsi cédé 3
mille abonnés ou je ne sais pas quoi
mais contenue au super qualitatif je
trouve ça dommage qu'ils aient pas ce
qui est pas se savoir met à disposition
c'est très très difficile de savoir
comment faire en sorte que la
connaissance qu'on souhaite apporter sur
youtube soit soient prises par les gens
soient soient embrassés soient partagées
soi etc
c'est dommage est ce que je peux te
demander de critiquer un peu le débat
ton dieu qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que tu
penses que alors critiqué des bâtons
mieux c'est ça dépend de ce qu'on place
sous sous sous ce hashtag mois pendant
alors tu vois encore voilà un bel
exemple
quant à lancer le hashtag je me suis dit
ah je vois exactement ce que c'est et
puis et puis on t'écoute au fur et à
mesure notamment en participant à la
conférence au crack soucis comme si j'ai
bien compris en plus on sait on sait on
s'est greffée à cette conférence qui
était censé pas être à plusieurs
j'ai compris que toi tu y apporter un
sens très différent de celui que
j'apportais au moins c'est plus dans un
communiqué une une réconciliation entre
le camp des sceptiques et le corps des
croyants et comprendre qu on est
finalement tous dans dans le même temps
le même bateau on est du côté de ceux
qui se soucient de savoir ce qu'est la
vérité si on peut résumer ça comme ça
toi tu étais plus dans une espèce de
tortue le corps ici je me trompe
d'optimisation de soi et de et c'est
très tournée vers soi dans le pas dans
un sens péjoratif dans le sens où tu
cherche vraiment à aller le plus loin
possible dans le dans la démarche
je ne trouve pas mes mots dans le fait
d'être irréprochable pour soi-même j'ai
envie de dire si ce n'est pas la chute
c'est très difficile à expliquer ouais
bah il ya un peu beaucoup de travail sur
soi
c'est sa gamme alors que moi je me
situais plus dans une démarche de jean
viii dire de terrain quoi tu vas 2-2
alors je sais pas est ce que je dois
critiqué les deux où est ce que je dois
critiqué la mienne ou est ce que je dois
critiqué la tienne pas ce que je vois
critiquer celles que je ne connais pas
commençons par la vienne la tienne ce
qui ce qui la tiennent elles mes frais
parfois parce que je l m'effraie
pourquoi parce qu'elle me renvoie à a un
goût donc c'est très subjectif que je
que j'ai connue principalement du côté
de la religion en fait notamment chez
les témoins de jéhovah où il ya une
espèce d'attitude idéal et en groupe on
est tous tournés vers cette attitude
idéal mais quand tu l'analyse cette
attitude idéal elle est presque
j'ai envie de dire inhumaines elle est
presque impossible il ya un côté
utopiste et et c'est ça qui me fait peur
c'est le alors c'est super de viser des
objectifs utopique et mam inatteignable
c'est absolument génial comme on dit
faut viser les étoiles pour but comme on
dit d'ailleurs mais il faut viser les
étoiles pour au moins atteindre le ciel
ou un truc du genre viser la lune
kerouay ya un truc c'est compris c'est
ce qui compte
et c'est vrai que parfois quand je te
lis je me demande si les gens qui te
lisent donc pas toi même si les gens qui
te lis vont bien comprendre qu'il faut
pas non plus tomber dans une religiosité
de l'attitude idéal qu'il faut pas
oublier qui on est dans tout ça est ce
qu'on est voilà ça c'est la critique
principale que je voudrais en faire et
je pense que aussi du côté des
sceptiques
j'ai déjà observé que ça pouvait irrité
de voir quelqu'un qui s'exprime
uniquement sur sur l'utopie à atteindre
mais qui nous dit pas qu'ils oublient
mais qui ne parlent pas assez qui ne met
pas assez en avant
l'acceptation de ce qu'on est ça c'est
la critique principale que je pourrais
faire à atton hashtag des bâtons mieux
si on peut dire ça comme ça
du coup tu penses que je devrais être
moi exigeant non parce que l'exigence
c'est bien je pense que tu devrais
passer plus de temps à rassurer ceux à
qui tu fais peur c'est à dire rappeler
que tu oui c'est un idéal etc mais que
tout à fait conscient que voilà comme
tout le monde
dubiez comme tout le monde enfin tu vois
c'est des trucs qu'on a peut-être pas le
rappeler comme ça mais c'est ma part
appelé en fait s'est rassuré sur le fait
qu' on reste tous humains et qui
évidemment il ya plein de situations
dans lesquelles on a on est tellement
contre 1 est acculé dans ce conte adumin
négatif par l'interlocuteur que ben oui
comme tout le monde on cède à la colère
comme tout le monde on cède à ces choses
là et on le sait et on le comprend et on
assume
je crois que c'est un truc qui rassurait
pas mal de pas mal de noms j'exagère les
quelques critiques que j'ai déjà entendu
par ci par là
c'est ce qui pourrait les rassurer un
petit peu parce que effectivement quand
tu es quand t'es pas déjà très imaginons
que tu as un des bunkers débutants n'est
pas très dans le débat ton mieux c'est
une notion un peu vague tu la comprends
pas trop enfin si tu comprends les
grandes lignes mais mettez pas non plus
dans à ce niveau de la réflexion et tu
vois quelqu'un qui qui a un tel retour
sur soi et qui est tellement dans
l'idéal de ce qu'il faudrait atteindre
tu peux le prendre comme quelqu'un qui
s'estiment supérieur à toi qu'est ce qui
n'est pas le cas et ce serait dommage
que le débogueur débutants et cette
conclusion parce que du coup ils
feraient demi tour de ça ce serait dire
il va devenir je veux pas devenir comme
ça que tu vois un peu ce que je dis je
crois que j'atteindrai ce que tu as dit
rapaille est aussi du vent le truc que
j'ai tracé que le des bunkers des buts
en phases francs plus de mal que de bien
plus
ah ouais non mais ça on est d'accord ça
on est d'accord mais là la question à
huit points à ses six l'objectif c'est
de faire en sorte qu'ils le comprennent
il faut éviter toutes les choses qui
pourront le faire s'éloigner du fait
qu'il le comprenne bien donc je le seul
conseil que je pourrais te donner c'est
cherche les petits mots clés les petits
les petites phrases tu sais tu parlais
une fois sur twitter que tu es très
attentif
je pense que à mon avis j'estime que etc
qui sont chez toi ddd petit élément
rassurant chez moi aussi d'ailleurs je
m'inclus totalement là dedans cherche
quels sont les petits mots clés qui
pourraient rassurer ces gens là tu vois
c'est permettre à ton discours de rester
dans leur tête
est ce que c'est important que ton
discours existe et reste dans leur tête
il faut pas qu il le rejette en se
disant à ce mec est complètement
irréaliste qui viennent voir un petit
peu ce que les défenseurs de je ne sais
pas moi la carotte noir parce que les
défenseurs on va dire et on verra s'il
fait encore le malin avec ses grandes
méthodes
c'est absolument pas vrai donc il faut
réussir c'est pas qu'il faut réussir
c'est que c'est dommage d'en n'ayant de
si bonnes intentions et dans n'ayant
ainsi beaux discours faire faire
demi-tour à ceux qui ont plus besoin
tu vois ce que je dis rien je vois ce
que tu veux dire alors j'ai pas j'ai pas
la réponse mais si tu me demandes une
critique ça va être celle là mais tu as
des idées et pas vraiment d'idée c'est
peut-être échanger avec eux quoi bon
alors après il se déclare rarement c'est
ça qui est compliqué aussi c'est que
comme tu as une certaine stature
j'imagine que les commentaires de ce
type sont assez rares et que ça se fait
plus tôt
en dessous parce que les débiteurs
débutants les bunkers débutants sont
aussi des souvent des youtube heures
débutant donc ils n'ont pas beaucoup de
chiffres et ils ont peut-être peur de se
mettre un grand youtuber ado tu vois
vous que ce que celle peut-être être
posé la question tout simplement sur
twitter comme tu le fais avec thé avec
des sondages ou je sais pas quoi
je crois qu'il faut pratiquer pour
trouver ces mots là moi je crois que je
dirais un truc du genre
dans un monde idéal où dans mon monde
rêvait tu vois je rajoutais le fait
qu'on comprend les qu'on comprend la
critique de l'autre un des petits
indices qui font que la personne à il a
quand même compris ma position parce que
je donne et c'est délicat
c'est le foot rien j'ai pas de jets pas
de solution toute faite
va te donner malheureusement c'est un
truc c'est un conseil soit qui donnait
dans les trucs livre sur mon mieux
débattre s'est passé vraiment beaucoup
de temps ces rencontres ont essayé de
comprendre l'autre mais cherchait à
ensemble clarifier ce qu'ils pensent et
quels sont ses points de blocage si on a
les quels sont les trucs intéressants de
ces réflexions et lui faire comprendre
qu'il ait compris
ouais ça c'est très important lui faire
comprendre qu'il est compris et qu'on
commence par l'accepter tel quel ça
c'est vraiment le choix
pour moi c'est le nerf de la guerre
parce que là le désaccord c'est pas
tellement le centre du problème parce
qu'on peut on a des tas de désaccord
avec des tas de gens qu'on aime pour ce
qu'ils sont et ont laissé pas grave
c'est une illusion de se focaliser sur
des accords je penses tu pas sur ces
nids des couettes donc de nouveau créer
ce lien d'amour je te comprends et je
respecte la position
voilà la base s'assurer que ça ça a été
transmis et après on peut aussi tu vois
moi je trouverais tout à fait légitime
que tu te dise
oui ben non moi j'ai envie d'avancer
dans ma voix ma voile laisse ces gens là
malheureusement derrière ils seront
récupérés par d'autres qui ont un
discours qui leur sied rail qui leur
permettra d'évoluer et peut-être à un
moment donné rejoindre mon combat désolé
mais je ne peux pas à ce point me
préoccuper de tout et je place une
limite je trouve ça parfaitement
légitime
c'est ce que j'ai fait par exemple
jusqu'à l'éducation et hématomes et
vidéos de matchs j'ai pas cela dit et
faire ça forum
je pense qu'il ya un créneau qui est
aussi important de l'action peut plus
avancer mais qui vise ont besoin aussi
de d'avancé les sexes sur des bâtons
mieux c'est un peu plus compliqué parce
qu'il n'y a pas deux il ya pas de
brousse bah oui je comprends je
comprends et je trouve ça très
respectable en fait moi j'ai tendance à
respecter les gens qui sont auto
cohérent tout simplement
c'est ce qui fait que j'arrive à
énormément apprécié quelqu'un comme
astronomique dont je suis l'antithèse
complexe dont je m'estime être
l'antithèse complet et il est frontale
il est enfin tu vois il est en dedans il
est insultant etc
mais il en est conscient il en est
conscient et ils l'assument et et il
assume les conséquences
et il n'est pas fermé à la discussion et
il comprend ton point de vue ils
l'écoutent jusqu'au bout tu vois qu'il
l'a compris et ensuite il est exposé le
sien et trouvent des raisons à lui de
continuer dans sa façon de faire à
partir de là je peux que respecter
ouais même si c'est dur sinon ça serait
quoi le point de désaccord dans le noeud
du désaccord d'à peu près 15 est
vraiment désaccord en désaccord sur les
façons de faire avec
contre toi et astronomiques la
frontalité même si moi aussi je suis
frontale parfois astronomiques c'est le
mec qui dit le prochain qui qui vient me
dire que les
les crop circle guérissent le cancer il
se ramasse un coup de calibre 25 dans le
cul bon c'est pas très bien richard lui
trouve ça justifier alors lui il trouve
ça justifiée parce que lui et il n'a pas
totalement tort et je vais pas parler à
sa place je veux donc attention 1,7 par
rapport à ce que je vais dire puisque là
je suis obligé de parler à sa place lui
il trouve ça justifiée parce que
certains profils ne réagissent qu'à ça
et j'ai été obligé de l'admettre il a
raison certains profils ne réagissent
qu'à la claque ce sont pas les profils
majoritaire mais effectivement j'ai eu
plusieurs témoignages qui allaient dans
ce sens d'ailleurs totalement par hasard
après tu peux être autant bienveillant
que tu veux il y en a il y en a qui vont
réagir au fait d'avoir été secouée
violemment à un moment donné et il faut
que ça existe donc je m'estimais plus si
tu veux en droit de dire ne fait pas
comme ça
ouais alors là pour le coup je suis je
suis d'accord avec ça je pense que c'est
une vidéo du débat tenu que j'ai pris de
faire du bien tout le temps mais fera
que la sorte un genre c'est la
différence entre au coup de poing et un
coup de pouce je pense que le coup de
pouce ça ça aide mais le couple a aussi
peut aider en effet près j'aurais
tendance à quand même penser que les
coups de poinçon efficace uniquement
dans la mesure où ils sont assez rares
et bien donné oui on est d'accord là
dessus
est ce qu'il ya eu trop de coups de
poing de la part d' astronomique
personnellement je le pense lui ne le
pense pas pour d'autres raisons
notamment le fait dire ça marche pour
lui donc pourquoi est ce qu'il est
pourquoi est ce qu'ils feraient un
virage à 360 degrés il n'empêche que ils
restent ouverts à la discussion il est
ouvert à ce débat avec énormément de
bienveillance et de cordialité
ça reste un type que j'ai eu beaucoup de
plaisir à rencontrer en vrai il est
extrêmement généreux il extrêmement
gentil beaucoup plus que dans ses vidéos
beaucoup de prudence dans ses vidéos
mais ça je crois que c'est un peu notre
cas à tous
donc je m'inclus vraiment en premier
plan là dedans donc le personnage voilà
c'est ce que j'appelle autant cohérent
situe à partir de là ma première post us
ça va être de respecter respecter ça
alors après on c'est un débat qui n'a
pas fini de on a prévu de se voir et de
faire un live sur ce sur ce sujet quoi
tellement c'est tellement on n'est pas
d'accord mais tellement nos arguments à
l'un et l'autre sont intéressants et on
est bien obligé de reconnaître l'un
comme l'autre que ben ouais en fait ces
deux postures incompatibles doivent
exister mais je suis bien content que ce
soit quelqu'un comme arnaud d'humains de
chaleureux et généreux qui occupe la
posture du coup de poing je serais
vraiment plus dérangé que ce soit une
personne hargneuse et est en colère et
en guerre contre contre le monde entier
c'est intéressant ce qui est ce qu'il ya
des choses qui pourraient te dire qu'il
pourrait te faire changer d'avis sur sur
ta façon de faire je sais pas dit leur
donner ce qu'ils voyaient un moyen de
questions et les trucs qui te ferait
changer d'avis sur la l'importance de
son approche principalement mais mais
mais qu on appelle ça mes mails via
moins ça reste toujours par rapport à
l'objectif est simplement si je vois que
quelqu'un d'autre atteint mon objectif
avec une autre méthode et il arrive plus
efficacement
je vais vouloir absorber sa méthode
quitte à abandonner la mienne j'ai
abandonné déjà la posture du sceptique
débutants fut un temps je préparais une
émission 100% consacré au sophisme
elle n'est jamais sortie quand j ai
travaillé très fort je les ai tous
répertoriés
je les ai analysé je les ai classifiés
j'ai fait un travail de dingue et s'est
jamais sortis à cause d'une simple
discussion avec christophe michel qui
est particulièrement doué pour me faire
changer d'avis sur ce que je crois il
fit
et voilà tu voyages et il ya des leviers
il ya des signaux d'alarmé alarme qui
sont toujours en lien avec l'objectif
alors est-ce qu'on pourrait me faire
changer d'objectif que tu penses que
astronomiques et toi avait des objectifs
trop différents c'est plus au niveau des
objectifs ou d'efficacité des méthodes
alors en fait plus je parle avec lui
plus je me rends compte qu'on a les
mêmes objectifs c'est ça qui est assez
fou en fait il a alors de nouveau je
parle à sa place c'est pas très bien il
a un objectif pédagogique par rapport à
ces vidéos d'astronomie et il ay là
aussi il ya aussi une dimension dans ses
critiques malgré lui
c'est assez marrant d'ailleurs je vous
hais le constat que les gens disaient de
lui qu'il est un et éthicien mais ils ne
le font pas pour quelqu'un comme primum
non nocere et que moi je considère comme
plus faisant plus de pensée critique que
castro nos geeks donc voilà ça c'est
assez étrange d'ailleurs bon il
n'empêche qu'il a cette démarche les
l'opération crop circle était quand même
assez magnifique dans dans sa structure
est dans le succès qu'il a eu le mérite
amplement
et le fait qu'on se retrouve a parlé de
ça avec passion de notre désaccord sur
la manière montre qu'on a le même
objectif en fait oui alors après voilà
ce qu'ils y arrivent ou pas je sais pas
en tout cas il ya eu du transfert
d'abonnés de chez lui vers chez moi et
ça a fonctionné de dire que les gens ont
trouvé chez lui et chez moi des trucs
killers qui leur convenait quoi tu vois
et je trouve ça aussi je trouve ça
intéressant
moi j'ai moi j'ai une hypothèse qui est
que toutes les toutes les pédagogies
sont comme des postes à pourvoir si tu
veux et je suis content que entre entre
différents types de pédagogie on
s'entend d'entre nous même si on est
même si elles sont contradictoires même
si elles sont à l'opposé
parce que quand les gens vont avoir
l'ensemble de ces pédagogies différentes
ceux qui vont retenir c'est que la
zététique c'est ce que j'espère qu'ils
vont retenir c'est que la zététique
pensée critique où l'esprit critique où
tout ce que tu veux c'est pas les
pédagogies ou les attitudes de chacun
mais le dénominateur commun et ça ça
m'intéresse énormément donc j'ai envie
de cultiver cette différence au
contraire et que tu penses que tu penses
que c'est ce que j'ai pas l'impression
que ce soit vraiment l'impression que
les gens ont d'elle et éthique
aujourd'hui annoncé pas le cas mais je
pense que l'arrivée de l'été titien
beaucoup plus soft comme christophe
michel moi même ou pas juste moi je sais
toujours pas si je fais les gens disent
que je suis soft je me trouve absolument
1 montre que en fait cette idée de sofia
soft c'est en fait pas de la zététique
et même si à l'image des éthiciens
arrogant qui revient régulièrement
je pense qu'elle est beaucoup moins
solide qu'elle ne l'était à l'époque du
cercle zététique ou avant qu'on arrive
sur sur la place publique je pense que
l'image est éthique seniors alors pour
ce point précis je pense que l'image de
la zététique s'améliore mais se
diversifie et ça c'est bien je pense que
maintenant les gens pourraient avoir un
débat spontanée sur la question de les
études sociales sont hilares au blanc je
pense qu'à l'époque il ya de cela quatre
cinq ans c'est un débat qui devait
apparaître de façon moins spontanées
sont des a priori un mais je pense je
pense qu'on a que le fait qu'on amène
une diversité des approches fait que
justement on en retient le dénominateur
commun et j'invite énormément d'ailleurs
mais mes collègues que soient privés ou
ou dans les vidéos à faire la
distinction de ce qu'est la zététique et
ce qu'ils en font tu vois quand quand la
tronche-en-biais demande à ce qu'on
fasse un effet streisand d'une vidéo ils
font pas de la zététique il utilise la
zététique pour mener une action
politique et moi et moi ce que je dis
c'est pas précisé le légat dit le dit le
voilà à table attention ce qu'on fait là
c'est pas de la zététique mais voilà et
à partir de là tout devient bon
plus respectable en fait ouais je pense
qu'il a essayé d'autocritique au sein
des et éthiques pas du tout non car même
si c'est un des piliers fondateurs de la
discipline mais je pense qu'il ya pas
assez d autocritique
je pense qu'elle passait enfin il ya une
auto critique globale mais chacun
personnellement oui on est tous en train
de faire notre autocritique mais mais on
voit pas les lignes bouger beaucoup mais
qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'on va faire at il
faut noter que je te critiquent leur est
dédié tic bousculer les lignes justement
moi je pense qu'on devrait publier plus
de contenu qui nous concerne nous en
fait on est toujours en train de prendre
des débits non alors il ya cette idée
comme quoi les choses dont on parle ne
sont que des supports pédagogiques qui
est complètement fausse évidemment mais
j'aimerais bien qu'on s'utilise nous
mêmes comme support pédagogique un peu
plus c'est à dire qu'on utilise
moi je suis moi j'ai aucun problème à ce
qu'un ascain youtuber amis amis inconnus
et c'est reprennent une de mes vidéos et
en fasse une analyse et éthiques ouais
j'aimerais bien que ça ça existe plus
c'est pratiquement absent est carrément
même
allons-y cherchons des défauts dans la
chaîne hygiène mentale quelques
j'idéalise beaucoup hein mais allons-y
quoi prenons le problème à l'envers
creusons le mettons le sur la place
publique
il me semble non seulement ça mais en
plus vital et ça permettrait d'arriver
dans une esthétique un peu plus 2.0 si
je peux exprimer comme ça ouais
j'étais à critiquer une vidéo de
christophe c'est vrai car il faudra que
tu me montres tactile a parfois que j'ai
contacté christophe cdc une critique
d'un corps bah dis donc une tradition
apparemment c'était une vidéo il faisait
il prend t system un système de tekkaman
mais il avait mis balzani sme dans le
système au le vilain éthique remarqué et
mais ça c'est soft tu vois c'est pas il
ne s'est pas une critique
comment dirais-je méthodique c'est une
critique de fab et théologique c'est une
critique de contenu moi je suis moi j'ai
vraiment envie confie qu on fasse une
analyse voilà qu'on montre les limites
de notre discours qu'on montre ses
failles comme entre les moments où on
biaise qu'on insiste dessus qu'on le
remette ça en avant quoi c'est pas assez
mis en avant
il est temps que j'ai en fait je le fais
beaucoup pour moi mais je n'ai pas
encore j'ai en projet un jeu évidemment
une galaxie de documents que j'alimente
en permanence j'ai en projet une vidéo
très copieuse qui critiquent la
zététique à la base le grand possède la
science c'était censé être satisfait la
série de vidéos à laquelle tu as
participé
j'avais leur âge d'ailleurs ça au début
ça s'appelait le grand procès de la
science et de la zététique mais savait
pas du tout plu mais moi je voulais que
kiki et des critiques de la zététique
danse dans ce truc là et est
malheureusement elles sont pas venus
c'est resté sur la science donc pas on
va les faire nous même c'est pas un
problème mais voilà cesser les
tentatives que je fais pour s'appuient
alors je j'utilise souvent c'est des
termes comme les et éthicien la
communauté sceptique pour pour la
critiquer dans mes contenus mais je lis
mais je ne pointe jamais du doigt comme
je peux pointé du doigt
jacques grimaud patrice poyart tu vois
tu es l'homéopathe tel machin
oui et je crois que c'est ça qui manque
c'est le sait le même traitement avec
qui je pointé du doigt un été tissés en
particulier ouais ouais ouais je
voudrais avec respect et bienveillant
mais mes jeux on a peur de le faire
passer par une résolution des ben oui
c'est très vous et moi en tout cas je le
dis je lui dis franchement que n'importe
qui se lance il n'y a aucun problème je
l'appelle de mes voeux congés non plus y
être quoi il ya de quoi critiquer le jeu
- et un rationnement pas ça qui manque
mais je critique et une vidéo qu'a fait
sur etienne klein
c'est vraiment à 100 et pour le coup je
te je te plus soif on en suit rassure
sur l'idée en tout cas de ces
initiatives
ça sera effectivement tous les faits
mais il ya vraiment en fait des trucs
sur lesquels j'ai pas mal mise à jour au
cours de l'année dernière c'est les tous
les risques liés aux effets de groupe
sous-estiment vraiment les risques des
effets de groupe à cette terrible et
c'est vraiment quelque chose de terrible
du coup pour garder des groupes qui sont
aussi sans que possible aussi bien
fonctionnant et kiki des visites et
génère pas en meute qui aboient à tout
bout de champ et qu'ils raillent 38
partout sur twitter je pense que c'est
très important que les groupes fassent
beaucoup plus d'autocritique et quelque
groupe que ce soit mais je suis
complètement d'accord avec toi mêmes
mots les mêmes les groupes dans les
groupes je me suis surpris alors ça
personne ne le sait évidemment je me
suis surpris à dire dans certaines
vidéos la communauté sceptiques pensent
que est en fait je faisais référence à
un tout petit groupe sur twitter où on
et 4,5 à s'échanger des messages
ouais c'est super dangereux quoi tu vois
c'est là en l'occurence n'était pas
grave ça méritait pas un erratum
mais je me suis dit ouh la vache qu'est
ce que je suis en train de raconter quoi
sans m'en rendre compte
tu as donc c'est que c'est à l'intérieur
c'est inscrit c'est le groupe dans
lequel je suis représente la pensée
critique
attention danger est quoi ouais c'est
vraiment dangereux et c'est un truc et
c'est de plus en plus à l'esprit enfin
disons une ville au 2 juin gallas
récemment qu'il est qui qui est ouverte
qui invitait beaucoup plus à la critique
en particulier balises à nice mais
d'être inefficace qui sont responsables
de groupes auquel je m'identifie le plus
aujourd'hui c'est de l'ocs et c'est un
vrai danger quoi je faut absolument que
je sois beaucoup plus critique de tous
ses mouvements en même temps un tout en
étant dangereux c'est aussi un
allez ça a évidemment beaucoup de
bienfaits ça reste un raccourci tu vois
on réduit le nombre de personnes donc
l'échangé plus fluides les informations
passent plus vite
il ya des avantages donc c'est vraiment
je voudrais pas non plus donner
l'impression que je voudrais que ça
n'existe pas est-ce que je vais
effectuer
il ya une méfiance terrible qu'il faut
avoir vis-à-vis de ce genre de choses
surtout quand on quand comme nous on a
une audience qui commence à devenir
conséquente quoi est-ce qu'on influence
vraiment la société mais avant une
influence va typiquement le voir le cas
récent qui à mon sens complètement
dégénéré mais c'est le cas de nos
sections sais pas si tu as un avis par
rapport à ce qui s'est passé
oui bon à mon avis est que 1 2 les
intentions étaient bonnes le le texte
était pas un mauvais texte
mais après moi tu vois ma démarche je
les utilise un mot dégueulasse de gros
néophytes
je me considère constate east c'est à
dire que ce que je constate
ouais n'est pas ce contre quoi je dois
lutter mais ceux de quoi je dois partir
si tu veux donc le nov excellente je
l'avais lu avant jeu j'avais un petit
peu critiqué en off on pendant sa
construction va en privé avec avec l'un
des membres en plus donc même pas très
sérieusement j'ai pas de gros lien avec
900 juste deux signataires et puis après
j'ai voulu défendre et pour moi tout me
semblait dans le vert le constat ça a
été que pas du tout la réalité ça a été
une grosse claque
je vais pas me révolter contre la
réalité tu vois je vais partir de la
base bon résultat à quoi nos fesses
saillantes plus la réalité égal ce qui
s'est passé ce qui s'est passé est la
réponse qu'on les aime ou qu'on n'aime
pas qu'on la trouve juste ou pas juste
c'est la réalité
à partir de là j'ai un petit peu quitté
le débat parce que j'ai vu qui
s'orientait dans tes
des pinaillage qui me semblait tout sauf
centré sur le message premier de la
tribune
et puis aussi la tribune n'était pas il
y avait un exemple de tribunes qui me
semble être un succès c'est la tribune
dauphin km
et là la direction que la tribune no
fake saemss a pris était pas du tout
celles de nos facs med
donc je me suis dit bon ben voila je
garde le hashtag mot fait que ça y est
ce parce que ça reste une idée ça reste
un concept qui me séduit mais après je
n'ai pas commencé à défendre bec et
ongles un truc qui qui est si mal
compris il sait qu'il doit être
considéré dans tous les cas il a une
responsabilité la responsabilité c'est
d'être compris devant les intentions
étaient bonnes
le message était pas si mal je trouve
mais le corollaire c'est qu'on s'est
gouré quoi et du coup qu'est ce qu'est
ce qui s'est mal passé et comment est ce
qu'on fera qu'est ce qu'on peut faire de
mieux la prochaine fois
moi je crois pas que ce message doit
être adressée dans une tribune en fait
pour moi c'est un truc qui est interne à
la profession et je pense qu'il faut
sensibiliser cette profession pour
qu'elle s'exprime beaucoup plus sur ce
sujet je pense que comme nous les et
éthicien avons peur de pointer du doigt
une vidéo de machin je pense que les
journalistes ont peur de pointer du
doigt les de dire vraiment voilà tel
journaliste a dit une connerie dans tel
truc ça se fait mais c'est extrêmement
rare ils mettent leur carrière en danger
en tout cas ils le pensent ils sont mal
vues etc et avoir la bonne prudence pour
dire ces choses là c'est pas donné à
tout le monde c'est très difficile de
trouver les bons mots qui vont qui vont
montrer qu'on jette pas à l'intégrité de
la personne on la considère pas comme
une méchante dix jours ce truc de
gentils et des méchants aussi terrible
quoi donc c'est marcher sur des oeufs
mais moi je pense qu'il faut aller
voilà autant no fake med c'était quelque
chose dans lequel l'opinion publique
comptait énormément parce que simplement
le public est demandeur de ces médecines
autant le no fake séance le public n'est
pas demandeur
le public ne demande pas demande demande
de l'information scientifique quoi tu
vois qu'ils qu'elle soit clivante ou pas
oui le public demande de l'info cliente
maintenant le fait qu'elle soit qu'il
vente ou pas ne relève pas du fait
qu'elles soient scientifiques ou pas
donc je pense que c'est un truc qui doit
plus s'attaquer du côté des journalistes
en de même moi je dirais sensibiliser
des journalistes en fait même si je suis
pas du tout légitime pour le faire mais
je regrette par exemple que quelqu'un
comme aude de la chaîne aux doigts de
fée que tu vois qu'il ya un petit peu la
journaliste de la commune je regrette
qu'elle n'allait pas dans cette
direction quoi elle est un peu trop dans
la défense du journalisme pur et dur et
la restauration de l'image du
journaliste et itérative justement la
dernière vidéo d'aude et très critique
des journalistes
ce que je comprends mais il faut aussi
apprendre à dire ce qui va pas chez nous
quoi
moi je n'ai pas hésité je pense à
quelques fois cité ce qui me plaisait
pas dans la tronche en biais typiquement
à l'époque où ils ont fait leurs lives
sur goal sur jacques grimaud lendemain
j'ai fait j'ai fait un billet pour dire
je me désengage complètement d'avoir
fait la promotion de cette émission je
ne suis pas du tout satisfait de cette
émission
ouais ça fait un petit drame à ils ont
refait un poste à un truc etc puis deux
puis on est devenus potes etc
il n'empêche que les attentes que
j'avais partagé j'ai dit voilà je lis la
tronche-en-biais je suis pas d'accord et
qui l'ont fait mais j'aimerais voir ça
chez les journalistes
et puis ceux de critiquer et c'est là
que des bâtons mieux avec des gens c'est
important c'est ici mais oui tu vois on
est on marche sur des oeufs en
permanence un évidemment et on peut pas
exiger à ceux qui savent pas que c'est
possible de mieux débattre de ne pas
mieux débattre donc c'est difficile quoi
c'est très difficile c'est très
difficile et délicat mais il faut
sensibiliser aller dans ce sens-là moi
je moi j'essaye d'intégrer saramon
discours en tout cas c'est pas faire
mieux que ça ouais et très très crue je
sais pas si tu as d'autres messages que
tu aimerais passé
deux sujets que tu voudrais aborder
n'ont pas trop jeu
j'espère que je vais pas me vautrer avec
entretien épistémique pas ce que c'est
c'est une très grosse responsabilité que
je me donne lui pratiquement personne en
parle ou en tout cas ceux qui en parlent
non pas le succès qu'ils méritent par
rapport à ça c'est très très bizarre
vidéo est ce que je vais prépare alors
je vais d'abord tenir les promesses que
j'ai tenu à terminer les vidéos que j'ai
dit que j'allais terminer mais ça c'est
ça reporte déjà de 2020 la démarche mais
l'a par exemple ce week end je donne ma
première conférence israël ça qu'on
sacré à ça elle s'appelle alors je vais
aller rechercher le titre parce que je
suis vraiment merdique toutes les
questions de mémoire
elle s'appelle comment faire comprendre
à quelqu'un qu'il a tort et pourquoi
c'est une mauvaise question
voilà c'est vraiment une conférence qui
va présenter l'entretien épistémique
c'est le premier pas que je fais là
dedans elle va être très inspiré
évidemment de tout ce que fait un animal
n'a bosco puisque j'aurais voulu faire
des entretiens épistémique par skype etc
j'ai sollicité un petit peu dans les
commentaires mais malheureusement je
crois que je serai pas prêt à temps donc
je devrais utiliser ces entretiens 8
comme exemple ça c'est un petit peu
dommage
et même si c'est un mauvais argument je
trouve quand même que quand la personne
qui te vends une méthode montre qu'elle
exerce la méthode c'est quand même un
petit peu mieux coin ça je pourrais pas
le faire tout de suite
ouais mais je compte faire des
entretiens épistémique vraiment avec
avec des gens et aussi avec des
sceptiques très important parce que les
résultats sont souvent stupéfiants en
fait
est-ce que ce serait vraiment très
intéressant de faire ça avec des loyers
voilà quoi dijon et titien et essayer de
montrer que parce que c'est la question
c'est une des questions les plus
récurrentes en fait c'est comment
comment on veut on veut tous bien
discuter les uns avec les autres en fait
on en a envie quoi on aspire qu à ça
mais on n'y arrive pas parce qu'on n'a
pas le moteur embarqué ouais ouais
du coup le principal frein je pense que
c'est parce que les gens
on paye des outils pour bien débattre ou
totalement totalement ça c'est une des
choses dans laquelle j'ai le plus haut
taux de conviction c'est une question de
méthode
autrement dit c'est une question de
trucs et astuces autrement dit c'est une
question de chance d'avoir été mis en
contact avec ces trucs et astuces ouais
ouais notera un autre impression que
j'ai beaucoup avoir organisé plusieurs
débats des bateaux mieux sur des bateaux
y aurait parlé à ma sauce us et qui fut
un des gros prennent ce que je vois
c'est que les gens ont beaucoup d'excès
de confiance sur ce qu'ils pensent être
une bonne façon de débattre et du coup
ils s'appuient ils pensent souvent que
savoir déjà je sais bien débattre ils y
sont peut-être parfois courant de
pâtures bien appliqué des méthodes
débattre mais une simple qui manque
beaucoup de réflexions sur la finance
qu'est-ce que bien débattre quelles sont
vraiment les objectifs
exactement ben écoute jeunes j'espère
que tu me feras une critique de ma
conférence
normalement ils devraient être filmées
et retransmises mais rien n'est moins
sûr parce que c'est le dieu de la
technologie mais vraiment c'est ce que
je m'efforce de faire c'est avant tout
faire un constat un constat des outils
utilisés et et les outils dont on a plus
connaissance mais je vais pas venir dire
mon idée alors si j'en viens à dire que
ce que l'entretien épistémique et mieux
que le reste je pense que j'échoue et
moi je veux juste que les gens aient
conscience de ce qu'ils sont en train de
faire quand ils font quelque chose bien
et c'est à eux de décider si c'est bien
ou mal si ça correspond pas à leur
objectif mais je veux juste qu'ils aient
conscience de ce qu'ils font
je serais très curieux de voir ça m'aura
page et qu'il y avait pas mal de vidéos
d'anthony mahdia bosco du oui bah tu
vois le mal que je vois je vois le truc
mais c'est vrai que c'est un truc enfin
moi même parce qu'il ya le mot à dire un
an
je pense qu'il faille ignorer beaucoup
beaucoup de ces méthodes beaucoup la
psychologie qui va derrière et je
constituerai estimer l'importance des
arguments en fait me semble assez
secondaire parce que on n'a pas le temps
de bien réfléchir aux arguments
notamment et notamment je parle beaucoup
du travail sur soi parce que je pense
que face à des trucs que je sois que
j'ai quand même pas mal mise à jour
enterrement après avoir lu le livre
feeling good ou
où le livre after having pensée molle
discussions parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
travail sur soi qui vit largement
faisable si c'est un autre truc c'est
que la première fois qu'on veut a
raconté des passages de feeling good sac
ma réaction c'était c'est sans doute la
réaction de beaucoup de gens qui me
lisent et ces sentiments-là contre eux
c'est comme ça ça peut s'appliquer en
théorie mais en pratique c'est mort
partick et moi j'aime m'impliquer ça et
faire un petit à petit je me suis
surpris à piquer un peu ça de plus en
plus ouais oui c'est des a priori qui
nous en fait on se met tellement de
limites soi même on s'en rend pas compte
et en même temps la surestimation c'est
tellement omniprésent je crois qu
absolument chaque vidéo que j'ai fait
tu sais une vidéo tu commences à acton a
priori en fait tu crois que tu as une
connaissance d'un truc je te dis je vais
la donner
et puis tu dis bon ben je vais quand
même documenté mon propos que j'ai
retenue y aller tu te rends compte tu
grattes du grade du gratte l'étudiante
futur je n'attendais pas du tout à ça
mais là j'ai retrouvé de même pour la
terre plate j'ai trouvé ce à quoi tout
cela je voulais faire un truc rigolo
elle je me suis retrouvé avec une
cosmogonie avec ses règles avec ces
trucs bien foutu et c'est vrai on
surestime tellement de choses et en même
temps comme tudiants on se sous-estiment
aussi par rapport aux choses qu'on
estime impossible d'atteindre de fer etc
peut-être qu'un jour quelqu'un me fera
la même critique que j'étais fait et me
diras métier tu es trop dans l'utopie
j'aurai en fait atteint le de l'état de
réflexion dans lequel tu es j'en sais
rien ça reste intéressant et je pense
qu'il faut prendre ça avec plus de
légèreté que le front du carburant qu'on
voit si ça c'est un des trucs que je me
dis beaucoup plus ces îliens pouillard y
ait du plaisir dans les petits progrès
individuels et c'est important
d'insister dessus c'est pas besoin
d'attendre la lune pour pour être
content de grandir un petit peu
exactement
elles ce sont de très belles paroles de
deux conclusions j'ai donné deux
dernières questions pour finir quel
serait le message un message clair que
tamara que les viewers retiennent de
cette crise auditeurs retiens de cette
interview de l'interview fini c'est
n'hésitez pas à critiquer les
critiqueurs pas franchement fait le
utiliser nos outils retourner les contre
nous même si vous vous plantez même si
vous ramassez des chips tort même si en
fait vous avez pas capté tel petit
détail
c'est important de faire exister le fait
qu'à un moment donné vous avez pensé ça
vieillit pas peur même si vous êtes de
youtube heures débutants et que les que
les gros youtuber se fâche contre vous
moi j'irai défendre votre cause
mais je leur dirai pas se fâcher contre
c'est con mais j'encourage vraiment ce à
quoi c'est bien de s'autocritiquer
individuellement c'est mieux de
s'autocritiquer en communauté mais je
rajouterai qu avec bienveillance a
minimisé les chances abbaoui et
bienveillance et tout ça et tout ça
c'est certain
maintenant on est pour beaucoup de gens
ont l'impression d'être bienveillant et
puis au final ils sont pas du tout
perçue comme bienveillant ouais moi je
suis prêt à faire l'effort de partir de
là priori que la personne est
bienveillante même si je me sens irrité
et agressé et est ce que tu vas finir
avec des recommandations de vidéos
podcasts livres au personnel suivre au
gie a pas grand chose d'extraordinaire
que tout le monde ne connaît pas déjà un
je sais pas je ne sais pas quoi dire je
j'ai toujours en plus l'impression que
tout le monde connaît tout le monde
alors que c'est tellement pas vrai
là aussi tu voir en surestime tout ça
ouais
je ne sais pas je sais alors tu va
recommander une chaîne même ma propre
chaîne je la recommande pas je la seule
chaîne que jose recommande slc hygiène
mentale parce que je pense qu'il a
vraiment c'est lui qui s'approche le
plus de la bonne attitude et de la
beauté de la pédagogie la plus large
je crois que c'est lui qui embrasse le
plus est qui et qui fait le plus de bien
ouais si on doit vraiment mesuré en
terme de nombre en termes de quantité
alors il est des gens sur le carreau ces
gens là se rattraper par une part
d'autres types de pédagogie etc bon bref
pas refaire ce qu'on a dit tout à
l'heure je ne sais pas trop quoi
recommandé non j'ai pas de et or pensée
critique je ne regarde que des trucs de
nazes tu vois des idiots minecraft et
tout ça donc je vais pas me lancer dans
des plumes des recommandations
auxquelles j'ai pas confiance pour être
ajouté à antanimena bosco peut-être
abbaoui anthony mcdo bosco évidemment
mais toi là encore j'ai l'impression que
tout le monde le connaît clairement pas
et d'ailleurs une bonne introduction à
anthony magna bosco c'est sa conférence
chez les ati ce qui s'appelle we are
doing to hang ouais ça c'est vraiment je
ne sais plus et sous-titrés ou pas mais
c'est un anglais facile ces pratiques
avec magna bosco c'est que c'est de
l'anglais très accessible fond c'est
quoi ça c'est ça fait du bien à l'esprit
c'est très très bon hockey
superbe merci beaucoup c'était super
intéressant
et toi pour les éditeurs je veux dire je
vous dis à la prochaine fois
probablement quelque chose